good morning members good morning
members of the public
you're very welcome here this morning we
have quite a long agenda and hopefully
you will all remain quite respectful of
one another and take it in the orderly
fashion that it should be dealt with
first of all I'm going to ask grab to
read out the health and safety
arrangements Thank You chair may first
remind you of some domestic arrangements
the toilets are situated outside the
meeting room opposite the stairs where
you would have come up cold water is
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room following the exit signs and meet
on if switch town football club training
pitch and please do not re-enter the
building until it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent thank you
this meeting will be broadcast live
through you too and will be capable of
repeated viewings the entirety of the
meeting will be filmed except for
confidential or exempt items if you
attend the meeting in person and make a
representation to the count committee
you will be deemed to have consented to
being filmed and that the images and
sound recordings could be used for wed
Carson and training purposes the Kensal
members of the public and press may film
record photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the press and public are
not lawfully excluded any member of the
public who attends this meeting and
object to being filmed should have a
file used the committee cloth as far as
I am aware no-one has indicated that
they will be filming or that they do not
want to be filmed is this still the case
you're all happy to be filmed thank you
baby District Council is voice recording
this meeting to which you cannot object
to in accordance with the council's plan
and charter members of the public are
not permitted to communicate whether
thoroughly or in writing with members of
the committee during the course of the
meeting including any adjournment
if a member of the committee is
approached by a member of the public
then they must immediately draw it to my
attention and also to the attention of
the legal adviser present if a member
the public attempts to communicate with
a member of the committee then they may
be asked to leave the meeting thank you
that's all the legal bit that we have to
do right substitutes and apologies
counselor substituting for councillors
that Norman thank you Jeff now before we
get into the meat of the meeting I feel
it's only right that we should perhaps
need to juice ourselves here so that you
know who is talking and what hope you
obviously the members of the committee I
will address them by their name but they
do have their name plates in front of
them I'll start with the first chairman
and we'll come this way
so perhaps you'd like to introduce them
I'm Steven Blum representative Chandhok
award and I'm the vice chairman of the
planning committee
my name is Ian Dupree I'm a solicitor
I'm legal adviser to this committee
today Thank You chair my name's Steven
Stroud on the council strategic projects
manager thank you Robert Carmichael
governance officer Jamie Mattox I'll be
livestream live-streaming the meeting
today
you
I'm Sam summers I will be presenting the
cuckoo Hill applications today
I'm Elizabeth one of the planning
offices I'm done your camera and I'm
planning officer Christine flipping
their planning solicitor Simon Bailey on
the enforcement officer Thank You chair
I'm Duncan Marin with the council's
communications team I'm Melissa villas
economic development intern just
training for me in today Harry Bailey
planning for growth in Zinfandel
preserving and only to be a representing
very : art and chairing this planning
committee meeting this morning thank you
all very much for that issuance of
interest
cancel the parka Thank You chair I will
declare a local number unary and the
three items of viewers by virtually the
fact that I was formally the ward member
for viewers and Mary prior to the recent
local elections thank you very much if I
might just jump in here councillor
Parker has two felsic rights and make
that declaration as the previous world
member just to say that members of this
committee and they were well aware from
their training of their obligation to
declare pecuniary ie financial and
non-pecuniary interest non-pecuniary
usually just require to be declared so
they're known and to be mindful of the
rules against bias and predetermination
I think it is known that our net our
neighboring council mid Suffolk whom all
the officers also work for have a rule
that the ward member does not vote if
there happens to be a member of planning
committee but just to make it clear we
don't have this rule at bay the council
there's a rule that goes beyond the
letter of the law that mid suffer clear
the chosen to have and Baber haven't the
ward member now happens to be councillor
Melanie Barrett since the boundary
changes in May councillor Parker and
cows the Barrett have both spoken to me
and I'm quite happy they've made a
sensible decision that they they are
quite that they intend to participate in
this meeting and vote and that's quite
right and proper yes thank you had
councillor Melanie Barrett decided to be
solely the ward member then she would
have only had been allowed to speak for
five minutes had questions and then may
have had to have left the room or that
would have been an end of her
involvement
whereas this way councillor Barrett does
have the opportunity to come in and out
the meat and like any other member of
the Planning Committee okay thank you
item three to compel the minutes the
meeting held on the 17th of July
they've all been circulated I'll go
through them by page stop me if there's
anything about them page one
page 2 page 3 page 4 page for you page 6
and the final page 7 can I sign these as
a true record proposed by Chancellor
Osborne seconded by Councillor plum all
those in favor please so that's carried
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
item number 4 to receive notifications
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme to get things
in order before we start proceedings on
the day so we have received one valid
petition with route with 20 valid
signatures which can be reported to the
committee today and I'll just read out
the which is cookie field viewers
retrospective planning permission should
not be granted for new applications we
the undersigned are secure that favor
district council planning committee does
not grow on retrospective planning up
planning permission for section 73
applications DC 1901 42 the reference
number of oh one 47 and oh one four two
eight which are all the applications
which have before us today chair it
should be noted with regards to this
petition that there were a lot there was
a large number of large amount of
support with regards to it of over 400
people however due to the way that the
petition scheme is we had to reject it
upon those
upon the grounds that information was
not provided in accordance with petition
scheme so with regards to what wasn't
provided was the petitioner scheme
requires that on electronic petitions
you have the name of the person and
their address unfortunately with the
ones that were submitted it had people's
names but it hadn't he had postcodes and
it did not have the further a piece of
information which we require of whether
they live work or study within Baber
as per the petition scheme the second
petition which is not being directly
reported to the committee today but is
for committees awareness is is that we
have received one as of yesterday from
mr. butcher regarding no confidence in
planning or enforcement at baby district
council this has been accepted and will
be reported to Council as an ordinary
petition but due to the fact that it
does not have it's not a consultation
petition in regards to the applications
of performance today that is what not it
is not being properly reported to the
planning committee and I'd like to point
out as well on that that there was also
a significant amount of support online
as well with regards to that but that
will be dealt with by Council and then
on to the relevant member or officer
thank you Jeff
so the petition that we have accepted
has been signed by how many people so
with regards to how many people validly
have signed it it is 20 which is which
is the which is the number which makes a
valid petition under Weber District
Council's petition scheme with over
other 400 which we had which are not
valid on that under the petition scheme
chair thank you yes so had they had more
time there most likely it would have
been more people but have to bear in
mind that we have to accept it legally
so that's the one that we're accepting
this morning okay members thank you
so we note that item valued is site
inspections
if you like to vote knowing the ones
you've got and then take us through them
you've got to I gather that's correct
oh yes there's a two sites being brought
forward for site inspection if you've
got the presentation yes both are
located in what field we've got lunch
the south of Norton Road and then land
south of wheat fields there we go so we
can see it now Sophie
technology it's wonderful when it works
just bear with us thank you so yes so
here's the red line sight for land to
the south of Norton Road the
applications made an outline for 15
units this is the site for the land
south to wheat field it's for 25 units
here's what field in its aerial view is
the linear run down and then the wheat
fields existing development it's a large
part in the southwest corner there and
then we've obviously got the school at
the corner and the bend there this is
the site layer as proposed for the land
to the south of Norton Road whereas this
is the site layout for and to south of
wheat fields the applications have been
brought before us following a request
for a site inspection on each and we
felt it probably expedient to present
them as one item given that they're both
located so close to each other the
committee reminder to visit one it would
probably be useful to take the
opportunity to visit both at the same
time
here are some site photos this is the
entrance to the site along Norton Road
this is his entrance looking the other
way and then this is the site itself for
currently it's an agricultural field
with part of it remain as such this is
the site south of wheat fields looking
out south over the fields to the south
of wheat fields so again it's
agricultural land part that will
residential and the remainder will be
filled as well and then this is the bend
around the corner sort of schools off to
my right as I look at the picture and
then the road continues down you've got
the entrance to if we field just on the
left taken all together the sights would
create 40 new dwellings in what field
do we want to open up in my discussion
can you just tell us the ward member who
led Jameson house Lolita is present here
this morning so did you wish to make a
quick comment to get those individual on
their own and you could probably do it
with photos but to have both coming at
the same time II visiting the village
and see the increase in okay we quite
often have a lot of applications for
things at the same time but I take the
point that this is a small village
members are you happy that we should go
along for site inspection or do you want
to you're happy that you've seen enough
in the photographs to allow it to come
direct to us councillor Hinton that's
right
so the actual reason for a site visit is
to see the impact of these two
developments on the village itself is
that the reason why we're having a site
visit because normally we have a reason
why we can have a site visit that is
this correct if they could see the
counselor Osborne yeah Thank You mr.
chairman yeah I would also like to
concur there about the impact on the
village but I'd also like to know the
position of the highways and the
accesses to these sites which are though
the pictures are excellent and the
officer has put all these pictures that
we need on there I feel that it's a view
it would be a different different
situation so I'd go along with the
sizing right well it seemed a bit affair
and that you'd like the site inspection
all those in favor of a site inspection
please show anyone against no that's
unanimous thing kill there will be a
site inspection to that and kill
right members we now move to the main
agenda for the item number six planning
applications for determined by the
committee and we got 3/4 of Hill which
were taken in order as on the paper a is
for I think plus 1 and 2 is that correct
and B is the flat number 3 and C is plot
number 4 but they're all separate we
have public speakers and at the
appropriate times we'll bring them in
first of all yeah I guess a few words
Thank You chair
and before Sam presents the particular
items just really to give members a bit
of context in terms of where we are and
why we why we're here obsolete members
being asked to take quite an
uncomfortable decision today and indeed
bearing in mind a recommendation one
that is not popular and to that extent
actually the applicants themselves are
not entirely satisfied with the the
recommendation set out because of the
nature of the procedure the officers are
suggesting the council take ie section
73 a rather than 73 we are in a
situation where there are ongoing
appeals and in November there will be a
public inquiry in respect of certificate
of lawfulness refusals on +16 and then
an appeal in respect of the site wide
application that members will recall
they determined last year and refused
specifically because of the harm posed
by plots
five and six not unreasonably then the
applicant has submitted these
applications to ask members opinions and
seek direction on plots 1 to 4
effectively to regularize them which of
course in a sense will draw a line under
things and everybody knows where they
stand in respect of each of the plots
the Appeals will continue to run the
council will continue to fight in
respect to plus 5 and 6 and and the
certificate of lawfulness appeals where
we're still relevant but what we're not
here to do today is look behind the
original permission
on which all of this sits so the
considerations are quite narrow they
relate purely to plots
wonderful and once decisions are taken
today my understanding is from the
forcement colleague mr. Bailey that
we're in a position then to understand
where we are in terms of serving notices
a little bit later on so for now I think
I move over to Sam will present the
items in relation to those plots one two
three and four take us through Thank You
chair um there are three separate
applications coming forward today I will
give you an overview of the whole site
to start with and then we will go into
each application have your debate for
each application and have a vote and
then move on to the next application so
they will be treated as three separate
applications members today the
application for consideration is for the
slaughterhouse site on kakou Hill abusin
Mary members carried out a site
inspection on the 31st of July and had
the opportunity to see the site from the
gardens of two neighboring properties in
addition to walking the site itself
the applications are section 73 a
applications that is because the works
have started and they're almost complete
a planning permission was granted by the
Planning Committee and two permission be
1401 1:03 that was for the erection of
six two-story dwellings following the
demolition of the existing commercial
buildings and hard standing and
construction of a private access
driveway scheme to utilize the existing
vehicular access to the public highway
this was decided on the 11th of February
2015 these three applications today seek
retention of four dwellings which have
not been both built in accordance with
the plans that were agreed of that 2014
permission
Oh lovely the plan shows the site and
the three separate applications that are
outlined in red this is shown in the
context of the whole site so the three
application sites are here that we will
be deciding today and this whole outline
here is the complete site that was given
permission in 2015 the lefthand plan
shows the listed buildings in the areas
shown in orange all of these are great -
listed white horse house sits directly
to the south of the site just here with
the access point just here the green
hatching on the right hand side our
historic county orchard sites which have
now been developed the site is within
the built-up area boundary of newest and
Mary it's within the conservation area
and it's also within a special landscape
area this aerial photograph shows the
site as built in context to the village
and in particular to the neighboring
properties the site is here you can see
the four houses that are under
consideration today at the back here
plots five and six are here which do not
form part of this application white
horse houses just here the access here
there is a motor vehicle garage just
here biron house is located here which
is the nearest neighbor to these
properties to the east of the site are
some outbuildings within a yard
Bieber has carried out an independent
survey to show the topography of the
site this is because the site isn't in
it is elevated from kakou Hill as it is
on a hillside the plan can be found
after page 50 in your agenda there have
been questions around site levels this
plan confirms those measurements these
photographs were taken during the site
visit and show the site and Friends
field to the south of the site the top
left hand shows pilgrims garage just
plots over and five are visible with
white horse house on kaku hill just you
so that's white horse house and looks
five and six just that the top right
hand photograph shows white horse house
with pilgrims garage and byron house
which can just be seen in this corner
here the bottom right shows the garden
of white horse house with pilgrims
garage the top of byron house and you
can just see the tops of plots of one
and two poking out just here
and the bottom right hand photograph
shows white horse house with pilgrims
garage Biron house and the corner plot
at the corner of plot number one just
tucked in here the top left hand
photograph shows the access point from
cuckoo Hill with pilgrims garage and
also plots one and two plot six can also
be seen just here in white horse house
just in moving down cuckoo Hill slightly
and looking directly into the site from
the access which is just here you can
clearly see plots one and two and the
corner of plot three and also plot six
which is just sitting behind white horse
house the bottom right is taken from
over grass bank in princefield and shows
an elevated view of the site you can see
white horse house pilgrims garage in the
top of byron house and moving down kaku
hill again you can see plots five and
six behind White Horse house just these
two photographs are taken from
princefield byron houses visible on the
left hand photographs with plots one and
two being shown on the right hand
photograph
but is the general overview of the
application site in total now moving on
to the individual applications all three
applications are section 73 a and secret
respective permission but the houses as
built okay councillor Busby sorry chair
point of order go back to slide to the
outline that you've got there seems to
suggest that the axis takes the whole of
that strip I understood that the garage
owned a part of it so is that correct
we have done some research in from Land
Registry and the applicant does own the
whole axis okay
just repeat that so that's very clear
okay we have double-checked the Land
Registry documents and the applicant
owns the whole access thank you carry on
these applications see retrospective
permission for the houses as built the
principle of development on the site has
been established by the granting of the
2014 application these three
applications relate only to changes in
citing site levels region of sight and
fenestration members are respectfully
reminded that their that these are the
only points being considered today many
other issues have been raised by the
objectives that these are not under
consideration today application DC 1901
for - - relates to plots one and two
could you just remind us again the
points that we're considering today so
today members you will be looking at you
you are looking and deciding the
applications is built from the houses on
their fighting site levels reach an deep
site and defenestration nothing else
plots one and two or a pair of semi
detached two-story dwellings these are
located in the northwest corner of the
site these properties are nearest to any
other dwellings outside of the
application site byron house sits to the
west the plots one and two and shares a
boundary with plot one plots one and two
provide two bedrooms at first floor
level and an open-plan living space at
ground floor level there are no windows
to the side elevation at first floor
level which would overlook Byron House
because of its siting and height there
is some overshadowing this is not
considered to be unacceptable harm
from friends field you can see the
first-floor windows lots one and two
it's dead and again from the access
point you can clearly see the difference
in height between plots one and two and
Byron house which is this property here
it is noted that plots one and two sit
forward of Byron house which actually
gives more privacy to the private garden
of Byron house from overlooking from the
first-floor windows because of his
sighting this is the front elevation of
plots one and two and Byron house would
be touched just behind the front
elevation he shows the proximity to
Byron house which is just here
this is looking from the front of floats
one and two down side towards the access
with cuckoo he'll which is just here and
that would be plot six just the corner
of it there you can see the end of plot
six with white walls house behind and
the garage on the right-hand side the
photograph
this shows the boundary fence between
Byron house and plot number one this
photograph here shows the gap between
the two buildings the top left shows the
view from the corner of the plot looking
towards plot six and White Horse house
behind on the right is the view of the
corner of plot one looking towards Byron
house and the bottom left is the view of
Byron's hat Byron houses garden from the
front of plot one
on the left is the rear elevation of
plot1 the top right shows plots two and
three and also the roof of the plot for
just at the very end of that photograph
and run of buildings the bottom right
shows plots one and two with byron house
the houses are considered to reflect
local character with the design and use
of materials fenestration includes sash
windows which are widely seen in the
historic core of the village and is a
feature which is welcomed in the
conservation area the photographs were
taken from the first floor windows of
plots one and two and members had the
opportunity to go into the houses and
look out of those windows for themselves
on the left hand side is the view of lot
six with white horse house tucked behind
from plot to the middle is taken from
plot one working at looking across the
garden of white horse house the right
hand photographs show the garden of
byron house which only the corner is
visible from that first floor window of
plot one the to talk photographs are
taken from the garden of white horse
house looking at the front of plots one
and two which are the cream-colored
buildings and the bottom photograph is
taken from the junction of San Edmunds
lane with Sudbury Road
this shows byron house with plots one
and two in cream and shows how far
forward plots 1 and 2 set forward of
byron house
these three photographs are taken from
the garden of byron house plots one two
three and four can all be seen on the
right hand photograph this is the whole
development visible from byron houses
garden the application is not considered
to raise any issues of residential
immunity heritage consider the changes
to be minor and are not harmful to the
character of either the conservation
area or the grade 2 listed whitehorse
house therefore this application is
recommended for approval with conditions
are set out in the officer's report on
page 23 members are again respectfully
reminded that they are deciding this
application as built in relation to
sighting site levels region eaves height
and fenestration thank you thank you we
have public speakers for all these items
parish council counselor Jill Jackson
Jillian Jackson
you still only have three minutes
between you to speak so if it's mr.
Harmon
he's an objector I have him down as an
objector this last was for the Parish
Council we know we have a procedure here
and I'm sticking to the procedure the
parish council goes first and that is
Jill Jackson or there's Tim Thurber and
I don't know whether the two of you wish
to join together or whether you're doing
the whole three minutes yourself you
have three minutes in which to address
the committee at the end of it perhaps
you'd remain seated or standing as suits
you and I'll see if there's any
questions to you thank you
in July 2018 when Kevin Lee is seated
here called for a split decision on the
plots your esteemed chairman mr. beer
stated that the site must be considered
as a whole beers of Mary Parish Council
still believe this to be the case as
there are too many issues relating to
the whole site for a decision to be made
on individual plots these include
highways and access which your
questionable statements already been
made however let us look at plots 1 & 2
rich residential amenity overlooking
loss of privacy loss of light were all
significant factors for Barron house and
to town Hill wall tall from plot 1 to
Baron house is only three point three
meters and from plots one and two to
tech to town hill 19 meters both far
lower than the recognized standard of 22
meters to maintain privacy better plans
for fenestration could have been used to
offset loss of privacy but nothing could
be done to offset the loss of light with
buildings of this class close proximity
if plot one remains biron house will
suffer loss of privacy 2/3 side windows
the worst is where the second-floor
bedroom window in plot 1 has a direct
view into the kitchen of Byron house
Axew town Hill the upper floor windows
of plots 1 & 2
give a clearer view into the southern
second-floor bedroom window Bahrein
house would also lose privacy in the
back garden due to the differential in
ground-level height and increase in the
floor level of plot 1 future occupants
of plot 1 will be able to see straight
above the six-foot fence into the garden
at the Byron House the owners of Byron
House have lost natural daylight through
first and second windows on the east
side of their property resulting in the
use of electric lights and blinds more
frequently than previously see no.1
requires consideration of the scale form
and nature of adjacent development Baron
house built in 2006
is a one and a half story house not
through story as stated in the officer's
report the roof line is on a level with
that of White Horse house plus one and
two are not of the same scale and are
overbearing to neighboring properties
the siting of plots one and two has
somehow been revised as acceptable and
the position of byron house called into
question in 2018 this chamber echoed
with laughter at the site of the
inaccurate drawing of Centurions Lane
and Byron house in order to accommodate
the incorrect locations of the new
properties it is still ludicrous to
suggest that a property built thirteen
years ago is in the wrong place it is in
the place it was planned and was built
your planning officer says of the
impacts of plot one or two these are not
considered to be so significant as to be
unacceptable what is acceptable about
having an overbearing new building
causing loss of daylight and significant
loss of property to existing dwellings
thank you thank you very much that was
right on Terry yes the advice given to
me at the time was that we had to deal
with the application that was in front
of us but our ask mm oh just to comment
on on that and yesterday I think it was
the case rightly so that the applicants
agent and/or barrister referred to the
opportunity for members to issue a split
decision albeit very late in the day of
us having that request but of course the
application was for section 73 as a
scientist and members acknowledged that
right if so and determine the
application has exactly applying for and
set out in that respect members did
refuse the application purely because of
the unacceptable harms in relation to
plus five and six and as I said at the
start not unreasonably the applicant has
then come into this at these
applications to recognize the positions
of plots one for because the inference
is they they must be acceptable on
balance this is a question and it does
need to be answered because we are going
to a public inquiry in November where no
doubt
the appellant barrister will be asking
the council
what about plots one two four and there
needs to be an answer for that these
applications also seek to provide for
now which as I say draws a line narrows
the issues for the appeal and indeed
opens at all for our enforcement
officers to take appropriate steps thank
you no doubt see if there's any
questions from members to the public
speaker members have you had any
questions no okay thank you very much
I'll just serve the officer is there
anything you wish to commend not that
could you just because the lady bring up
being forward of bran house slowly
number 17 I seem to remember you shoe
you pointed that out do we know how much
forwarded that is just if not even kept
spying though I were debating that was
at 17 yes button one yeah you find it
there I can see I can see the white
rolling of the other of number one how
far forward is that the bit we refer to
so we do have you've got the answer now
I do need to check and Thank You
Geraldine to check its change well
perhaps you can find that out while we
continue the debate so far forward thank
you
members know you've done that there's no
other questions thank you very much
we'll get an answer to that as soon as I
can
right the next public speaker is an
objector Michael Harmon you sir also
have three minutes in which suggests the
Committee on sit or stand perhaps should
remain afterwards and I'll serve as any
questions for you when you ready members
I speak on behalf of keep yours
beautiful who represent 500 local
residents kpb invites you to postponed a
decision alternative Lee refused these
applications I'm a partner in homes and
Hills the firm's planning team is
recognized for his expertise I say there
are good
to refuse today's applications
consistency in decision-making but also
the impact on Buell's and its residence
indicates that today's applications
should be refused on behalf of KBB I
invite you to do so
I trust that members have seen my letter
of 24th of August which sets the tone
these applications concern not only a
complicated matter but a highly
contentious one as you're aware these
applications are correctly section 73 a
applications that cannot be a section 73
application which is forward-looking as
case in Lawson builders as a section 73
a application members do need to know
whether it concerns development carried
out without planning permission without
complying to some condition or other I'm
referring to the 2014 permission the
relevance is to the fallback position
and its weight
unfortunately the officers report does
not seem to assist you on this fallback
point if the 2014 permission has been
lost you may wish to ascribe little or
limited weight to it that would entitle
you to consider the detail of the
development and I emphasize detail if
the 2014 permission is extent then it is
the discrepancy between approved plans
and the development has built that is of
relevance so that's that is a critical
issue that will be decided at inquiry in
November experts will be providing
evidence as to measurements and scaling
of plans and legal arguments will be
made concerning the interpretation of
planning conditions so members may feel
that they're ill-equipped to decide
today prior to termination of the
inquiry but further members but also the
public and the applicant need to know
what is being approved or not from the
current application this is far from
clear given there appear to be issues
with submitted details and the
correctness or not of submitted plans
are referred to my letter those are
reasons to postpone making decision but
indeed any decision today will have
ramifications with inquiry but if
members do make a decision today than to
assist the courts have been clear that
approved plans are integral to
determining what the permission
authorizes 2014 sight levels drawing
clearly illustrates the intended roof
height as comparable to surrounding
dwellings particularly White Horse house
likewise the same drawing show the
footprint and relationship to
neighboring development so on a proper
interpretation the heights of plots 1 to
4 are clearly constrained as are their
footprint
and I suggest that was purposeful to
avoid the cooker here with development
being overbearing and bitterly dominant
but also to avoid an unacceptable
adverse impact on neighboring residents
any conflict should be resolved in the
favor of the 2014 drawings therefore
there is significant conflict with those
plans and and the development for which
you're being asked to retrospectively
approved the buildings are visually
dominant and overbearing that has caused
the justifiable anger of the local
community and you've seen firsthand the
impact of the development when standing
in neighboring gardens the council has
already refused to issue certificates of
lawfulness for the buildings in question
and has also refused to site wide
application for the development has
built those applications due with the
legal issues and planning merits
circumstances have not changed so acting
consistently members should refuse
today's applications there is also the
issue site-wide matters very much your
time as other thank you thank you chair
members is there any questions you got
for the objector canceller Buzzbee so
you say circumstances haven't changed
but in fact this application is for
what's wonderful as opposed to 1 to 6 so
we are looking at a different
application army it is a different
application but the development has
built has not changed since the previous
applications or indeed the certificates
of lawfulness for the individual plots
that's that's my point
thank you any other questions No thank
you very much if you wish to comment
what you've just heard just a couple of
small points chair I think in terms of
consistency of decision taking obviously
very important I think it's again
important to highlight the fact that
last year the decision taken 2 reviews
was solely based upon the unacceptable
harms of plot 5 and 6 in a in
prospective members being ill-equipped
to make a decision today and effectively
leaving it to the inquiry I make the
same point again the council cannot turn
up to the Enquirer and so it has no
opinion on plots once before that is a
question that
doubtless will be put to us and there
will need to be a response and officers
at this point in time in leading up to
that inquiry I minded to say blocks 1 to
4 are not so uh not so harmful that they
are unacceptable the focus of the
council's case as per the decision last
year is that plus five and six are the
unacceptable elements of the
developments thank you so you're saying
that what about happened if if we were
minded to refuse or postpone sorry
postponed you would come back to us
before the inquiry for our opinion to
take the view to the inquiry I think
there are a lot of possible permutations
here not least if if no decision is made
today the applicant may well appeal for
non determination which again will force
us to form an opinion it would be
unreasonable for the council not to have
one that's the answers yes thank you the
answer was yes we'd have to have an
opinion right any other questions that
okay we are now moved to the applicant
agent which is Kevin Lee if you like to
come forward sir and you also have three
minutes and which dress the committee
you can stand or sit and that should
remain there at the end I'll say there's
any questions for you thank you very
much thank you chair and members once
again I'm in front of you but as your
counselor noted there's been an enormous
change since last year unfortunately the
very long letter from the previous
speaker is one of those where had he had
time he would have written a shorter one
I'm sure in terms of facts this
committee or a version of it last year
only concerned itself with plots five
and six your officer keeps reminding you
that and it's a plain fact and it can't
be swerved around indeed everybody if
mmm focused on five and six and that's
important because at the time you'll
recall I asked for a split decision
apparently as we discovered later the
only reason you didn't give a split
decision is because you haven't done it
before it was a procedure you weren't
familiar
if you could actually have given a split
decision but you didn't but that left us
in the position that we had four plots
with which you weren't concerned and two
with which you were concerned and so
earlier this year myself and my clients
team met with your officers and we spent
a great deal of time working out how we
could all save a lot of anguish time and
expense if we could focus on what
remained between us that's why you've
got these four applications I'm not
going to deal with the difference
between section 73 and 73 a my main
concern is that you make a decision
today hopefully a positive one but we
had a meeting at which everybody agreed
that plots 1 to 4 didn't concern the
council didn't concern your officers
didn't concern the members as a result
of which you've got the four
applications this was brought in
effectively your encouragement as in the
council's encouragement so that when we
get to the inquiry in November which is
not going to last for four days and will
cost a lot of money and no doubt there
might be cost applications in it as well
we won't be arguing over things that
aren't in issue and although your
officers said this to you now several
times despite what the chap in front of
me said and the lady from the parish
council said your specialist officers
heritage officers you're planning
officers highways have all looked at
every single thing that the residents
could throw at it because this is really
about the residents driving it would
seem the council rather than the council
being in charge there isn't a single
issue left in planning terms there never
was and it certainly isn't one left
including access about plots 1 2 4 this
is your opportunity today not tomorrow
next week or any other time to say we
don't disagree and we would consider
plots 1 2 4 as built sufficient if you
do that that means the inquiry can then
focus on what's remaining plus 5 and 6
if you however decide to disagree with
your officer you're going to be in the
very difficult position of finding
evidence to disagree with a team of
professional officers who spent a great
deal of time on this
picking up the consistency point this
committee last year also decided there
was no problem he plots one to four so I
can't sugarcoat it
but quite rightly plots wonderful never
were an issue and it's time this
committee grasped the net very sorry but
your time is up thank you
I says there's any questions from
members there's a certain point that I
think we've brought out there that don't
require a response as to who is in
charge whether it's the council or the
residents
hence the Busbee so you say you said
that we didn't make a split decision at
the last Planning Committee because
we've never done any form didn't know we
could do so how do you know that we were
all in favor of plus one to four because
the report from your officers which you
accepted because you didn't say anything
to the contrary itself made no criticism
of plots one two for the report if you
draw it up only looks at plots five and
six that's why we met with your officers
earlier this year which they admitted
what we had already said and worked out
you never were concerned with plots one
two four had you been concerned with
plots one two four there would have been
a record on your minutes or in a
discussion and I was present at the
discussion and the whole thing I think
was televised then so we know what your
position was it was to focus on plots
five and six thank you yes well it's a
big assumption if you're faced with with
something which is really really bad
which let's say plus five and six were
you don't necessarily pay any attention
to something which is slightly bad
that's we did not make a decision I'm
sorry I've got to press you here
councillor buzz beer I might have some
sympathy but you do need to put a
question to the speaker
it's not fair to put other exes Asians
so if you've got a question I'll allow
it
no any other questions it canceled a
Barrett Thank You Germany and I'd like
to ask a little bit about the the
measurements
that have been in dispute on on the site
and we've got some detailed analysis of
that the the access driveways and
turning points how how much have you
realized that throughout this process to
ensure that the there is adequate room
for vehicles turning for deliveries for
parking and so on well that's actually
never been an issue but as part of
coming to today because residents keep
talking about access access off the
highway we have gone back over all the
drawings and again with highway who do
not make any objection to this and with
your officers we've reconfirmed that
what was designed what was built so far
because it's not finished and what was
approved all comply with whatever
requirements about going to the detail
whatever requirements highway needs so
again it's a red herring I'm afraid but
the whole issue of getting from the
highway onto the site maneuvering around
the site and turning or all matters that
were all sorted out previously and again
if we go back to the report last year
which is the one this committee looked
at and only focused on plots five and
six the access was not an issue
it never was an issue because it simply
complies with any requirements that need
to be dealt with had it been an issue
one would have expected either your
offices or this council to have made a
point last year and just if I made
picking up the council who was trying to
make a question the point he was really
trying to make was well we turned them
all down we were really concerned with
five and six but we might have been
concerned with one and four to a bit
I'm afraid that just doesn't wash that
will not serve us adequately and the
other crystal sorry I don't have a
question for me you said there was a
second point there's a second one
counselor
Parker see if you think so so much I'm
just pick up on your point that you
mentioned earlier that this this whole
case is being driven by by the residents
rather than by council
I would suggest that actually there was
ample opportunity for you to engage with
counsel when enforcement action was was
first mooted and indeed I raised this
point last year at last year's hearings
that in actual fact your client chose
chose at that time in fact to accelerate
the development rather than work with
asset as an authority so can you
understand this committee's reticence to
take on face value your your your
intentions and your words when the
evidence seems to be in an actual fact
you were gonna plan ahead regardless yes
it's a fair question I understand the
position you're in your people who are
elected by people who speak to you and
naturally you're influenced by them I'm
just a planning lawyer who for three
decades has spent time in the planning
world and therefore can only speak from
facts and law I can't speak from
prejudice and emotion my client hasn't
ploughed on of course the big question
which we can't answer today is what
we've built we still maintain is
perfectly lawful the big issue between
us if you recall from last year is what
we call under build the extent to which
the site can be leveled that's where
everything stems from I don't know to
what extent you've looked into the
figures in I don't know whether in this
report but I can tell you that the
figures that have been done by survey
and survey by agreement with the council
show that more or less every one of
those buildings is actually a little bit
lower than the approved drawings it's
not the size of the building from the
top of the ridges to the bottom of the
brick above ground level it is actually
the fact they're on the ground the issue
between them every time one of the
members of the public good falls or any
of you councillors or indeed the
officers get into the question of what
is it you've done wrong where we are a
party's not the construction of the
building they're more or less the right
height some of most
they're more or less in the right
position as it happens it's the fact
that the site had to be leveled and the
bit the inspector is now going to
determine although there is previous
decisions on this which we've shown the
council it's that levelling of the
ground and the council somehow will want
to argue the case well we're not happy
with the leveling we want to see the
whole lot pulled down our point is if
that had really been an issue you could
have in 2015 when granting consent have
put a site level condition in there not
uncommon they're not common but they're
not uncommon you could have a condition
which puts a ground level at a certain a
Adi you can have a height which perhaps
there's reference to something off site
those are all things which could have
been done I feel I have to come in there
a valet to the ground because levels as
you quite rightly say do seem to be a
great concern to everybody and I think
you have adequately said the situation
so I think I've got to stop it there
otherwise were getting into another San
Felipe I mean even always that's another
question of Hector and what I would just
ask to following on from that I've had
correspondence and I've seen letters and
and things that apparently the park and
the number one which tapers I think when
we stood on site is that still as it was
showed on the side planned last year
that would allow two cars to park down
the side there one behind each other can
I just check that detail got the
architect here let me just
doing the best as I understand it
because it's not an issue that's been
drawn through your officers to our
attention we think there's tandem
parking in other words one behind the
other but I think it's in front rather
than the side I think it may be your
officer knows even more than I do on the
point because I've got the architect
I've got the planner with me not the
architect but we think it's tandem
parking but again it's not a problem
that we are aware of thank you I'll get
the officers to come in after you finish
speak after the question Steve
any other questions members no okay
thank you very much thank you sir Thank
You members okay
can you know answer that for us please
and the parking arrangements do not form
part of this application however I'm led
to believe but I've made to believe that
the parking is satisfactory to Suffolk
County Council highways thank you all
right that's answered that we'll move on
the county counselor which is counselor
James Finch unfortunately is on holiday
now he did do a video which he wanted to
address this committee but unfortunately
because we would then want to ask
questions on that I've had to rule that
we can't accept the video after advice
after advice but what I have done every
member has been given a copy of his
speech because I did asked him to send
that in to us as well so that we cover
all angles
everybody's been given a copy of what he
wanted to say to us which were mainly on
highway matters they have been looked at
by the officers members have got copies
and I think there's been some copy
circulated to the public here today so
we'll move on unless any remember during
the debate wish to comment on any of the
correspondence that they've had well
that's an end of all the public speakers
the ward member is counselor
Barrett but I'm now going to open the
there's debate and I'm gonna start with
Ken Sala Lee Parker who was the original
councillor for viewers in the run after
all this and then that would be fathered
by councillor Barrett she was just to
speak cleanse live Parker yeah
thank you very much share her new clip
as close as possible to your mic I'll
scoot as close as I can Jenna thank you
so you know I think in my time on the
Planning Committee the issue and the
planning application of viewers has been
as contentious as any other application
that we've dealt with and we've forward
all this time and I personally still
feel that we have more questions and
answers with regards to this application
so I would I would urge members to you
know to ask each and any question that
they have pertaining to this application
today so when I was reading the report
over over last week and over the weekend
the same items have accrued again so
those are you know the big big issue
heritage I know we mentioned that
highways aren't to be considered as part
of this application but nonetheless
we've had correspondence as members
we've received correspondence over the
weekend which would suggest that
actually highways and Suffolk County
Council have and do have an opinion
contrary to what we've what we've heard
this morning and and I think we just
need to be really really clear about
what we're dealing with here you know
certainly one of the questions I had
over the weekend was it appears that
we're being asked quite reasonably we're
being asked to determine the application
as it stands ie if what is there now is
what would have been applied for back in
wherever would it would it have been
acceptable to us but at the same time we
can't discount the fact that everything
leading up to this is also much
to this application so for me there is
that there's that there's mixed messages
coming across there for me as a planning
committee member but I think it's
absolutely essential that we as members
really thrash this out and and and get
to the nub of it this morning chair I
will just say with regards to you know
our local community etc we you know
whilst we have to come to a decision
today that's either going to be a
popular decision or it isn't going to be
a popular decision contrary to what we
heard from the last Baker iyx pursuit
Lee absolutely applaud the local
community for for continuing to raise
these issues with us as an authority and
for keeping it for front of the agenda
that is not the community leading the
council that is merely our community
being our eyes and ears for us and we
are after all elected to represent those
communities so I make absolutely no
apologies for that chair and that's I
want to have a really good and involved
conversation around this whole
application today and I'm glad anymore
to say about that just now yeah I can't
elaborate thank you and good morning
everyone
really I'm not going to repeat
everything that councillor Parker has
just said but I'd like to just say I
know very well the level of opposition
to the application that we have and the
concerns that have been shared with us
about the accuracy and many other many
other concerns and and we've heard about
a petition from from local members and I
think actually you know the the fact
that so many people have actually
written their detailed concerns down not
just signed a piece of paper but but
spent the time to
why they feel this this application
presents difficulty to the to the
village is is a good thing where they've
actually linked it to planning grounds
not just objection once with emotion
emotional grounds it is a difficult
decision for us all and and we we are we
are very conscious of em to get the
balance right based on what evidence we
we are able to get so I'll be asking
questions as we go into the debate if
they're not already asked my fellow
councillors before making my decision
and so I you know save some third
comments for the debate thank you
well before I go to other members Simon
the enforcement officer has got an
answer to my question that I posed
earlier about how far forward that
particular was on slide 17 if you want
to just show it again I think it was 17
just over 1070 I think so on the plan
submitted with the original application
plus one and two would you two be lots
more than two would you two be about a
metre back from the rear elevation of
Byron House and on as they have been
built they are about three and a half
meters forward of the rear elevation of
Byron House
so full more forward I'm sorry to have
my someone's I was just making a note of
my colleagues comment I wanted to make
sure I'd heard it properly was it just
could could you say the measurements
again Simon yeah so on the original
plans under the 2014 application lots
one and two were located a little over a
meter back from the rear elevation of
byron house and as they have been built
according to our survey they're around
three and a half meters forward of the
rear elevation of byron house thank you
sorts I also whilst we're on that
subject can i clarify that the
measurements that we've taken on site
placed that building in relation to its
boundaries of the site where it was
intended to be in accordance with the
approved plans those there is not there
is not an issue with their location of
that building when you take account of
its proximity to the boundaries of the
site so the location of that building
Lots 1 & 2 is in accordance with the
approved plans when you measure to the
to the site boundaries
hopefully members this has helped you
all right there counselor Busby you see
four and a half meters away from where
it should have been but then you say
it's actually where okay so if I can
clarify then in relation to Byron House
the depiction of buildings on the site
versus Byron House on the plans that
were submitted with the 2014 application
the location of plots 1 & 2 was depicted
as being around a meter back from the
rear elevation of Byron House on the
plans or as on the drawings that we've
got from the survey the location of 1 &
2 is forward of the rear elevation of
Byron house but when you take account of
its proximity to the boundaries of the
site
it's in the right place okay so Byron
House was in the wrong place on the
original drawing well I I'm not drawing
that conclusion I'm merely illustrating
I'm not drawing that conclusion I'm
merely saying that when we've taken
measurements as up on a factual basis
the measurements that we've taken
indicate that that building is where
it's supposed to be thank you right I'm
sure that helps us
any other comments members Chancellor
Busby yeah I'm sorry Sam but he it would
have been barely more than that we're
looking at the change in sighting sight
levels but it would have been easy if
we'd have had one page with what the
changes are instead of all of the you
know these surveys look I have to say I
found it very difficult to try and work
out what what was originally agreed what
they built what they're now applying for
you know it's trying to see the wood for
the trees really I think you could have
presented that on one page it would have
been it would have made this decision a
lot easier a question how relevant is if
what they applied for in 2014
bearing in mind presumably they put
another application with separate
drawings etc and that is what we're
looking to approve or refuse now the
2014 application is absolutely important
the section 73 a zone in front of you
today are just amendments to that
original planning permission so the
principle has been set some changes have
been made to the buildings as built
members have had the opportunity to see
those in person
you've been inside the houses to see how
the community affects the other
properties around it you've been into
the gardens of the neighboring
properties to see how that is all
affected so I do take your point there
would have been nice to have the two
plans so that you could judge them side
by side however you've been on site
which is much more important councillor
Hinton thank you Thank You mr. chairman
based on what the the applicant said and
looking at page 14 of the papers in
front of us today looking at the history
of this site it appears that all six
properties had individual applications
refused for retention as built so
where's the five and six were actually
okay and so we're sort of problem here I
see your pride council Hinton if I'm
gonna ask the legal authority sir if I
understood my colleagues correctly there
were individual applications for
certificates of lawfulness that's
correct isn't it so a certificate of
lawfulness invites the council to agree
that something is lawful under planning
law and I think the point is things can
quite easily be irregular and lawful but
actually the council might decide might
this your decision today whether you do
or not to grant permission for for it
and if I have if I want to build an
extension in my back garden if it's a
half a metre bigger than the
measurements allowed in the permitted
development order I it's not I won't get
a certificate of lawfulness for it but I
might get plowing Commission if the
council think it's alright so that
that's the kind of distinction we have
to be mindful of here and today Hinton
thank you thank you mr. chairman for
that so we're really sort of splitting
the hair right down in the middle army
as to whether it's certificate of law
from his old planning law that we're
actually talking about I thought they
were both bits of planning law
and if you haven't got a certificate of
lawfulness and you need planning
permission if you haven't got planning
permission then they fund nation that
seems the simple way but the way we
always we always say and I'm sure the
two planning laws in this room won't
disagree when councils consider
certificates of lawfulness with
extremely rare exceptions and it nearly
always not we do not consider the
planning merits we simply consider
whether planning law allows it as in
weather weather and and it was argued I
didn't deal with the certificates of
lawfulness a colleague of mine did so
I'll limit my comments but it was the
argument was that they were within
limits of Tolerance such that they
should be deemed to be lawful as that I
went looking is that more or less
correct and in fact but in fact the
council said no they weren't and then
inspector will never have to listen yes
that's it in a nutshell so there are
seven appeals all conjoined rolled into
one which we heard that the planning
inquiry in November six of them being in
relation to these certificate of
lawfulness applications which were
refused on the basis that from the
council's measurements and
considerations the as-built plots one
two three four five and six go beyond
the scope of the Planning Commission on
that basis they are lawful and it's on
that basis potentially that enforcement
notices could also be served
however there's then the the wider
planning aspect is it were in terms of
our these plots acceptable in planning
terms the council's very clear position
from last year is that plots five and
six and absolutely unacceptable and that
rendered the whole site or the whole
development as being a refusal which is
the other appeal that's being heard in
November as well however because the
reasons for refusal given last year
effectively was so clear that it spot
five plus five and six that is where
that unacceptable harm lies as we've
repeated so at the time so far the the
applicant has now submitted applications
effectively to regularize the positions
of plots one to four
there is a reasonable inference and
officers agree and indeed the
recommendation before we miss to approve
the plots one two three and four and not
unacceptable in planning terms thank you
any other comments
speak I'm gonna ask the enforcement
officer if he'd like to comment on that
can you comment Thank You jr. I'm not
sure I'm able to comment on whether or
not the OS matte layer is correct or not
the point I was making earlier was that
having taken measurements extensive
measurements of the sigh the the
position of plots 1 & 2 is accurate in
accordance with the approved plans
canceled about thank you I'm just moving
into a slightly different area chairman
can I I'd like to raise an issue with
questions over the consultation process
because I have been contact and I think
the officer has also fire resident who
is a lives very near to the site who
says that they have not received a
notification in good time for
contributing to the consultation process
can we be can the officer answer that
question the procedure for consultation
to makers can somebody in likeness yet
the procedures for consultation are set
out in the development management
procedure order of 2015 as amended and
that's been followed to the letter by by
the council and its officers which is
involved site notice letters etc it's
not necessary to capture every single
person but of course it's a wide enough
net so for people to be informed and
indeed people are responding then the
consultation in that respect as has
works but in the strictest possible
terms the council has followed that it's
a procedural matter as opposed to the
particular planning merits that are
being discussed today and of course if
the officers can respond to that as
necessary outside of the sport am i
right in thinking that we voluntarily
contact the neighbor each side of the
application side and usually in front
and behold but on controversial ones we
do tend to try and go and a wider scope
is that that's that's right and chair
it's a matter of judgment but
effectively it goes over and above what
our statutory requirements are canceler
bears Thank You chair and I'm just a
little bit confused could I just check
so slightly different and according to
Anglian Water there was no response but
the viewers Council and the hamlet both
and were worried about drainage has that
been resolved one of the problems with a
drainage do you have a page number
anything that you're in from on off page
16 that's I think what what counselor
has is is knocking on the door of is
this wider point in terms of what the
status is of the the 2015 permission
upon which all of this sits now if
members make a decision today to follow
recommendation those approvals
effectively sit alongside that host
permission which continues to have
effect and when members approved the
development of six dwellings back in
1415 they considered and they must have
considered that otherwise they wouldn't
have gone to Planning Commission that
the development was achievable and that
that encompasses the land contamination
issues the access issues what we have
what when the number of what we're doing
today here is looking at the particular
siting and presentation whatever you
want to call it as set out in the
description of those dwelling plots four
one two three and four the requirements
for the right why the scheme remain
extent it remains the case that there's
a permission for the dwellings known as
five and six albeit we're saying that as
built they are wholly incorrect and
unlawful but it remains the case that
there is a permission for
just as a matter of clarity can you
explain extent because this is extremely
expensive extent because this has come
up many times and people are not clear
perhaps you can explain it but simpler
so understand it I think from and it may
be always better to chip in but I mean
effectively from the counsels or the
officers position there was a permission
granted
and that was lawfully implemented within
the time limits
there were pre commencement conditions
that were discharged and they've gone
about developing the site where they've
gone wrong is in respect of those
particular dwelling plots so the
permission itself is still there and
there is a theoretical possibility that
they could complete the development in
accordance with the plans and and it may
be the case of whatever enforcement
steps are taken next we'll be seeking to
ensure that that could still happen just
to aunt chairman I mean I think I'm sure
that two other missed the two lawyers in
the room had this experience it but a8
Planning Commission for a very large
developments and large housing states
say can be commenced by doing some very
moderate things like starting to dig dig
holes dig foundations lay out access
roads and I'm sure mr. Harmon and Kevin
have had to had clients coming to them
in a bit of a panic sometimes saying
we're about to run out on the three
years or the two years and you know the
Vice clients to dig some holes and take
some photographs with dates on and so on
and then if you've done that you can
then complete the development goodness
knows how many years later I mean it
looks as looks of it on tidy and doesn't
impress people if you do that but it
cantaloupe is quite lawful I think so
what I mean what this leads to is you
can have a development that's lawfully
commenced and that you've been told pre
commencement conditions were discharged
in a proper way that's that may be an
obstacle in some cases I mean you really
have to be very radically wrong
- not lawfully commence the developments
if I if I have a permission for one
house in the northwest corner of the
field and I dig a hole in the southeast
corner then you could say I'm not I'm
completely wrong and I'm starting to
build something that I've not got
permission for but if I think in this
case it is the Pierce has been my
officer colleagues view and I seen the
sense of it that the development was
lawfully implemented and commenced and
therefore on a worst-case scenario for
the applicant they could still build in
accordance with it even if they have to
do lots of demolishing Thank You
councillor Barrett
thank you just going through some some
issues that I have on the going back to
the highways issue on on this side not
just the access into the site but I
raised it earlier with the applicant and
planning barrister how can we be sure
that with the new measurements that
apply to the site new placing and citing
that the the highways aspect is still
currently there is no objection from
Southern highways but because they that
was extent I don't know whether that's
part of that that arrangement the Year
30 how can we be sure that that is still
applies when there is some difference is
in in siting of the houses Soviet County
Council highways were actually consulted
on this application and they've come
back with no objection they've seen the
changes that have been made to the site
and on that basis they've raised no
objection sorry I'm just to add cuz I
think you know it's important that
people have raised the the comments
received back from the highway authority
do go a little bit further than that
which is correct but effectively what
what they've gone on to say is that they
were objected they would objective
effectively the conditions or the
expectations of the original permission
are unachievable and an officer's
opinion it remains the case that the
development is still achievable and in
respect of those highway matters and
again we're back to just looking at
those individual plots that sit within
that wider development that is approved
mr. Bailey
thank you change the enforcement officer
just to remind you yeah thank you chair
just to clarify the layout of the
development is in accordance with the
approved plans it's it's counted round
slightly within the site so that plot
five is closer to the southern boundary
but the measurements between each of the
buildings relative to one another is in
accordance with the approved plan thank
you so my point being that there should
be sufficient room within the site for
the for the driveways and parking
arrangements to remain as they are we
are asked to consider fenestration but
we haven't heard anything really about
fenestration what is the particular
aspects of fenestration that we should
be considering
fenestration is the window and door
positions and their styling which you
saw on the elevations drawing I can
bring that back out for you if you wish
so that you can see them
so that's probably easier the actual
photograph so that you can see them
there have you only Balkans to Barrett
however others wanted to speak I'll come
back to you yeah
cancel the Busby okay so we've looked at
the sighting we've looked at
fenestration the one thing that we I
don't seem to have an exact figure for
is the change in site level Ridge and
Eve's height to me the end the only
important thing is the difference
between in the old plans the difference
between the rich height for Byron house
and the ridge hike for plot one as per
the plan and the actual difference
between the bridge heights now can
somebody tell me what those two figures
are afraid the comes back to assignment
again can you give us what was
originally the reach height and what the
rich how it is now between the two
properties I would need to work those
two out but the difference is no it's
not sorry it's not I do need the
enforcement officer to actually give an
answer to that and he will what his
answer will be the exact answer that we
will have to accept so he needs to be
clear and he says he'll get that
information for us I can do that while
we carry on thanks miles thank you sure
but I have got a vigor which is good
which is plot one plus one and two nor
point three nine meters higher than was
approved which is about three nine which
is about one point two feet in old money
one point two feet if you if you want me
to find out what was approved and what
they are at now I can find that
absolutely
yeah that's the difference not by 3 9
meters
thankthank of her supposed to be that's
quite a good point
any other comments cancer the park thank
you
yep just a couple really if I can just
deal with the legalities that there
seems to be a little bit of issue around
ownership of the access and and who is
in clear ownership and that seems to be
contended but in any event can you just
clarify to what extent how much weight
do we need to give to ownership in any
event as a planning committee doesn't
matter whether it's here or wherever how
much weight do we need to give to
ownership matters concerning such such a
matters access ordinarily very little
unless it were absolutely clear that the
permission was frankly unachievable but
in this instance officers don't believe
that's the case we have checked the Land
Registry details as recently as this
week not least for the site but also the
garage next door and it appears that the
applicant owns that access albeit there
is a right to use it for the garage next
door
councillor Parker so to clarify that
point then irrespective of whether you
know whether that fact is right or wrong
it's immaterial to a planning decision
it's a consideration effectively we
would give incredibly little waiting to
I mean ultimately again going back to
the 2015 the permission that was issued
it was off the members considerations
there that the permission was achievable
and that still remains the case
regardless of whose particular rights it
is to use that access enforcement
officer Thank You Jay we have the Land
Registry mapping page open in front of
us and the east side of the access is
under the ownership of the developer the
west side of that access is currently
unregistered
Sam can you bring up the site location
for me please
so on within that within the blue line
area at the bottom of the site the
eastern half of the the access road is
within the ownership of the applicant it
looks like that on the western half
there is no current owner it's
unregistered it's not the issue we're
talking about the ownership of it please
don't interrupt the meetin sir please
I'll try and get the answers I can see
the ladies Howard up a document which is
showing that there is a right of way I'm
going to ask the legal people here to
comment on leave or folks work how do
you do that
Jeff are they we sorry Jer if I may we
have the title documents before us and
they show that there is a right to fly
over that area the point we're making
the only point we're making is that the
western half of the access area is not
currently registered with an owner
we'll carry on any other comments after
the question water the start somebody
said that the strip guess the Busbee
sorry it hasn't changed we're looking up
to clarify the detail that's what we've
been doing whilst we've been going
through the meeting with because of your
question we've clarified the detail
councillor Barrett thank you
on the the access part I know the
highways of not raise an objection
but if omit because this in part is an
it was an existing access from previous
use if this was a new brand new housing
development and we were talking about
access where a business was operating
and vehicles were moving in and out
reversing in and parking for short
periods and so on would this really get
planning approval with that sort of
access or is it really because it's it's
got a history of use in that in that
manner I know we don't have anyone from
highways here to answer that but can you
possibly give a give some view on that
yep we're getting an awesome well I
think there's there's two things
ordinarily going back to the ownership
and rights-of-way points it's the
age-old thing that planners will say to
you these are civil matters and we don't
really get involved in those it remains
an issue to be dealt with between
whichever parties are relevant whether
there is a an agreement or whatever to
be struck but the fundamental point here
is there is planning permission for the
use of that access for six dwellings and
as we've said that permission
stance and that is the situation as it
is that's a decision that was taken by
members objected to in in so far as the
development remains achievable which is
precisely the case yeah okay thank you
chancellor Parker Thank You chair right
heritage so much was obviously made last
year of the Heritage impact and and you
know the setting or upon the setting of
the of the heritage assets etc etc and
obviously last year was considered that
the the harm to the heritage asset was
significant and yet in this report we
are being asked to consider that there
is now only negligible harm to the to
the asset now we're talking about site
here or the dwelling situated within the
site as a whole but it just seems to me
that this is a very subjective matter
over over whether there is harm caused
or not and I understand the sliding
scales etc etc so I think last year we
were looking at something that was of
well significant less than substantial
harm or whatever the phrase is whereas
this time we're being asked to consider
that there is as I say negligible harm
to be cut so can I just have can can an
officer just explain to me how on earth
that works you know given that we were
talking about buildings that are only
meters apart why is there now considered
to be negligible harm to the heritage
asset well I don't think there is an
inconsistency going back again to 2015
members considered the Heritage Matters
and felt that the development as a whole
was acceptable what's changed and the
decision that was taken last year was
that plots five and six was so you know
grossly apart from what was approved
that the the difference or the you know
however you want to cut it the impact of
those plots five and six gave rise to
such
sniff acun or you know approaching the
higher end of what might be considered
the spectrum of harm was unacceptable
and that was purely in relation to plus
five and six the heritage officer in
this instance has been asked to look at
plots once Paul has considered them and
and his judgment which of course members
went on to reach an alternative judgment
and is that there is no harm all the
harm is so trifling that it effectively
is immaterial to to any balance and and
that that is it in a in a nutshell thank
you
any other comments remembers counselor
Barrett and I'll come to you next
do this have a point to make about
remediation on the site on the
recommendation it talks about
contamination remediation agreed in
previous application so as I understand
it every mediation was removal of some
of the the land to to a depth that was
agreed I think you would expect that to
be been taken care of
although the site is still you know it's
not dug out especially can you just
confirm what the arrangement was for
that and these lots of soil has been
brought on to the site in order to level
it and therefore the land contamination
officer would like some more testing to
be done that can be secured by condition
that is one of the conditions that is
attached at the end if you reminded to
actually approve the Lots one and two it
is in order we have the wording for that
condition I put it here if anyone wanted
to see it but it is in hand land
contamination did form part of the
original application and it was agreed
but because more soil has come onto the
site which has the potential of being
contaminated
that's why further conditions are
required for them
termination those are our conditions
covering that cancel Oh plum Thank You
chair I like to offer this the
enforcement officer question if I may
Simon and if this application is passed
and the ones four three and four what
would be the enforcement offices next
action with regards plotz five and six
Thank You counsel excuse me our course
of action relations have last five and
six probably be to serve and enforcement
notice requiring them to be demolished
how quickly well it would the
legislation requires that it takes 28
days for an enforcement notice to come
into effect and we would need to give a
reasonable period for the demolition to
be achieved so I think we'd probably be
looking at three to six months to get
that work done if I may when would it be
served
Thank You Jer we were probably certainly
would be aiming to serve in relation to
the decision notice that goes out with
these applications thank you because
members I have to remind you we are
dealing with +12 in front of us
any other comments none forthcoming
well members you're going to leave me in
know the only course of action I will
have will being sorry sorry sorry we've
discussed all that members is there any
other comments well then you're leaving
me with no option but to oh yeah ken's
councillor pop right Thank You Chet so I
think if you know if I'm my chair if
you'll just allow me I think you know I
think what could what concerns us more
than anything here is elected members it
jars chair that we see I perceived a
perceived injustice which to a certain
extent was was addressed in the in the
application last year the difficulty
that we have here now of course is that
we are being asked quite rightly and
reasonably and to make decision based
purely upon planning planning only
planning merit it is not within the gift
of this committee to to to not approve
something simply on the basis that we
feel that we have been slighted in some
way that that option does not exist for
us we can only take a decision based on
the planning aspects that are sat before
us and in full accordance with the
National Planning policy framework and
I've listened to some of the submissions
that the councillors have submitted here
this morning
and I I do rather I do rather fear for
for example for the community that we're
probably heading towards a decision that
may not prove to be particularly popular
but we are members of the planning
committee and sometimes we have to take
tough decisions and I'm not sure if
members have completed their
deliberations around this or not but
clearly we need to get a proposal coming
forward so if I can just get that back
to you it's German thank you very much
for that well I asked again
okay slab plum thanks chair as much as
it goes against my heart my head says
that we have to approve this and I
propose that we accept the officers
recommendation much to my regret but
that's more like thank you I now have to
ask for a second death Chancellor
Osborne
yes Thank You mr. chairman I have the
same feelings as perhaps all of them
members here have however on the site
visits that I've taken place on those on
that particular application I feel that
the applications for one to four of the
houses I'm afraid we have very difficult
with a very difficult position in
actually refusing it and I would go
along with counsel plan to recommend
approval and my view was that five and
six was the main problem when I visited
the site and therefore that will be in
turn taken taken in view thank you
I'm assured that we will not be fighting
the appeals of any less bigger than than
what we've got that the officers will go
hammer and tong forward on five even six
regardless so just to be clear there
I've had a proposed and second death so
any other comments before I put this to
the phone
you are clear this is a very important
application we've listened to all the
views I think councilor parkour summed
it up very well for all of us it is
difficult but members you must make a
decision now councillor Hinton you
wanted to come in sorry mr. chair just a
quick point before we actually vote I
wasn't present for the the previous
decisions on concerning this application
site it's a complicated site I was there
for the site visit I've seen what the
site looks like now in its sort of three
quarters built state and I'd have to say
that I would have to have had serious
doubts about approving it in the first
place but in the spirit of different
consistency in terms of planning
decisions from this committee from his
council having refused each individual
plot on a certificate of lawfulness
which is accept their solicitors saying
that it's different from from planning
reasons but it's not that much
difference it does revolve all in law as
a planning issue I'd have to say that if
we were going to be consistent we'd have
to refuse it thank you was the only
comment and though I think that's all
been said any other views before I put
it to the vote
well I've had a proposal by the vice
chairman councillor plum seconded by
Councillor Osborne that we accept the
officers of recommendation all those in
favor please show
yes though is it against that is that is
carried permission is granted for plots
one and two we need to move on and no I
think we need to deal with the other two
we can't keep you waiting any longer
right well we'll know members move to
item so you be on page 54 Youth Samantha
[Applause]
what's the holdup no we're gonna get
these done because people are waiting
okay the second application can be found
on page 55 of your agendas this
application relates to plot 3 under
application DC 1901 4 to 7 plot 3 is a
detached 2-story dwelling with attached
garage this is a three-bedroom dwelling
with some traditional detailing which
includes a jetted first floor a chimney
relatively small windows the use of
materials are characteristic of viewers
these are photographs of the front
elevation these photographs are taken
from the first floor window
the views are of plots 5 and 6 and the
garage on the right-hand side plot 3
does not raise any issue of residential
amenity and heritage have raised no
objection to the scheme this application
is recommended for approval with
conditions are set out on page 65 of the
agenda thank you thank you for that row
parish council
Jill Jackson again
Buse village and its residents have had
to suffer ongoing issues related to this
development you impart the inexcusable
delay by the council in initiating
enforcement proceedings once it was
apparent that planning permission have
been breached and later when
retrospective planning permission was
refused had enforcement proceedings
commenced earlier when they should the
council was bound to have refused the
planning application by virtue of
section 70 of the Planning Act it
appears that the applicant by bringing
an appealing lawful development
certificates development certificates
has deliberately forestall the beginning
of the enforcement proceedings to get
around section 70 but this reason
amongst others the council should adopt
rigorous approached the application
taking full account of every significant
reason why the previous application was
refused difficult to see how the council
consents ibly consider this application
without first deciding the enforcement
steps we've heard the idea of the
enforcement steps but we've got an
appeal to see to first I can't just say
that that's what's going to happen in
six months demolition this application
invites us to consider a house which is
screened by a property which is not part
of the current round of applications
this meeting does not actually know the
outcome for plot six which is subject to
an appeal not to be heard till November
if we are asked to imagine the impact of
plot three without plot six then some of
the objections to plot six as we've said
is so important and upheld by the
Planning Committee in July 2018 are
leading to refusal if Commission will
have now applied to this this plot the
difference between plot six and plox
three is proximity to the listed
property plot three has an oversized
relationship with the adjacent rodas
sized traditional vernacular property
white horse house when plot six isn't
there the unacceptable harm previously
attributed to plot six was contrary to
paragraphs 17 56 57 and 64 of the
National Planning framework in that it
doesn't not secure high quality
design is not a good standard of amenity
for all in future occupants of land and
buildings does not contribute positively
to make the place better has not
achieved high quality does not establish
a strong sense of place use streets
gates buildings to create attractive
comfortable places to live work and
visit does not respond to local
character and history reflect the
identity of the local surroundings and
materials these issues do not relate
solely to the proximity of the plot two
white dwarfs house so are not solely on
plot six and five of we've been
mistakenly led to believe this morning
in John Davis planning office for beta
in July 2018 saw this development as a
pause design that failed to take the
opportunities available for improving
quality in character of the area and the
way it functions so I invite you to
dismiss this application on the grounds
cited by your own officer last year
thank you very much and just remain
there for a moment
enforcement officer did you hear the
start of the lady's speech
well I encounter all that I'm going to
allow you one minute to start from the
beginning again because I think in
respect to you you deserve to have an
answer to those points that you put
forward but you was out of the room so
if you just go on for one minute and
I'll stop you which I think will pick up
all the questions you posed to the
enforcement officers okay
yes village and its residents have had
to suffer ongoing issues related to this
development due in part to the
inexcusable delay by the council in
initiating enforcement proceedings once
it was apparent that the planning
permission had been breached and later
when retrospective planning was refused
had enforcement proceedings commenced
earlier when they should the council was
bound to have refused the planning
permission by virtue of section 17 it
appears that the applicant by bringing
an appealing lawful development of
certificate application
as deliberately force toward the
bringing of enforcement proceedings to
get round section 70 for this reason
amongst others the council should adopt
a rigorous approach to the application
taking full accounts of every
significant reason why the previous
application was refused it is difficult
to see how the council consents ibly
consider this application without first
deciding what enforcement steps should
have been or will be taken including
what will happen to plots 5 and 6 I know
that you said that the enforcement would
be put into place and that they will be
divulged in fact 3 to 6 months but how
can we know that they're subject to a an
appeal which is in November thank you
very much I think that was the bit that
he he missed can you answer that for us
I think it's very important to serve
some house yes thank you Jay I think
with the benefit of 20/20 hindsight we
would have preferred to have taken
enforcement action earlier but it's
reasonable to offer the opportunity to
the developer to resolve breaches of
planning control in this case through an
application and that's what we would do
with many other situations involving
breaches of planning control is to
invite the applicant to remedy the
situation either through an application
or through removal of the offending
matter
we haven't served notice in respective
this development yet our our principal
issue in terms of what's wrong with the
site is plots 5 & 6 as has been
indicated earlier and previously by
Planning Committee last year
5 & 6 were the most offensive of the six
that were granted permission in
2014-2015
as per mr. Lee's comments earlier when
he was speaking we met with the
developer back in January of this year
and the conversation at that time was
that lots one to four were largely
acceptable and applications brought
forward would be subject to
recommendation for approval and that's
the situation we now find ourself in it
would be unreasonable for the council to
start launching into enforcement action
when it's inviting applications to
remedy the situation that it
the developer finds themselves in and
that's what we'd normally do with any
application try and solvent thank you
right members any questions to the
parish chemistry no okay thank you very
much the parish counselor has mentioned
what would happen if plots five and six
were to be demolished and what effect
that would actually have on whitehorse
house the 2014 Commission did actually
give permission for a two-story dwelling
on both of those sites so the screening
would still be there for white horse
house just a plan for you thank you now
go to objector Clair through him you
have three minutes of which has dressed
the committee and at the end of it but
should remain seated or standing now
service any questions for you thank you
thank you my name is Claire Ferrand with
my husband and our three children here
today we've lived in Whitehorse house
now for thirteen years we feel fortunate
to own a grade 2 listed building and we
value its history but our home is now
dominated and overlooked by the site's
windows look into our kitchen and my
children can't play in the garden
without that every move being watched
this is despite a 9 foot fence hastily
installed ahead of your site visit in
October 2017 two years ago we could see
how much the grounds on site had been
raised the enforcement case was opened
and we breathe the sigh of relief
instead the pace on site visibly
increased up to 12 hour days six days a
week and the house is shot up plot 3 is
over 2.6 meters higher than Whitehorse
House original plan has showed the same
roof level at just over 20 meters away
from us on ground now two point three
meters higher the house would would to
tower above us both the ground floor and
virgin windows would look straight into
a home and garden surrounding houses
Whitehorse house byron house cook who
helped cook Ubar nervously
all have the same roof height as our
home and as you've seen plot 3 dominates
the skyline by meters how can the level
of harm identified last year by heritage
across the site the whole site have just
disappeared this year plot 3 is much
closer to us than the 35 meter distance
required to avoid overlooking how can
the harm caused by plot 6 to whitehorse
house disappear by a matter of meters
and why is it not been applied to plot 3
the final access is still uncertain but
a 2.3 meter difference in ground height
means it will be a steeper gradient and
recommended by highways
yep unfortunately not heard of James
Finch his piece and he made this point
very clearly ramp shown on the plans
would need to be up to 10 metres long to
be even DDA compliant there's so many
unanswered questions how could potential
occupants even access plot 3 it's
unknown a retaining wall has been built
in the area previously shown on plans
for reversing from plot 3 I don't
believe there's still space to maneuver
a car and safely leave the site in
forward gear and this is all on a gray
gradient now of 1 in 5 we had the
support of councillor Finch in our MP
James Cassidy she's taking us to a House
of Commons instead my husband James and
I have been verbally attacked for our
concern that these houses do not apply
with the original planning permission in
emails were sent by the develop
developer to viewers primary school when
my children attend to failing me as a
governor and my character and with the
support of our head teacher we've had to
involve the police we've received
letters from the developer with false
allegations threats are taking us to a
court and the financial costs of this
process and this has happened because
we've stood up for ourselves and our
village but with a unanimous refusal
last year we know that we were right but
it's had a devastating effect on my
husband and I we're an ordinary family
but we've had to endure intimidation
slander and attempts to falsely accuse
us of criminal activity we're trying
hard to protect the future of white
horse house on behalf of us and the
village of furious people here today
please stop this happening
thank you all for that I've served as
any questions but members just remember
please refer your questions to planning
matters we note in here what you've said
but we have to deal with the planning
this
of it any questions no okay thank you
very much
is that it you wish to come in know what
you just heard no and that's the
applicant the applicant agent mr. Lee
you was to come forward and dress the
committee you don't have to but you have
three minutes if you wish to thank you
chair members again the sense of deja vu
I'm not going to repeat what I said what
I said the first time around counts this
time around but as I've got now about 2
minutes and 40 seconds I'm as we use it
can I pick up some points your chairman
quite rightly says decide this on
planning matters but no doubt you're
human and quite understandably you're
affected by what you hear it's not the
place for me to be able to defend my
client even at a planning inquiry we
won't go into a lot of the stuff that's
being said here but some points you want
to take away we never got the planning
permission for this site we bought the
site with planning permission we
inherited the site what we got is what
someone else got permission for so
there's nothing that we've done there's
no tricks we played we bought the site
and we built it as far as we're
concerned in accordance with the
permission that's the very question the
inspector will decide so no one at this
moment can be certain but it does mean
when people when people talk about
something is two and a half meters or
one meter or half a meter difference the
base point is still in dispute where you
start from the ground level is still
something that is not yet determined
secondly any enforcement notice again it
really isn't part of deciding whether to
grant permission whether you're going to
issue an enforcement notice but as your
officer will confirm it would be
pointless because the very thing any
forceful notice will decide is going to
be decided at an inquiry in November you
may want to start the enforcement
process that will be appealed and then
we'll all get running into another
inquiry with more costs and we will
certainly be saying the council
unreasonable if it pursues that kind of
action when it's going to have the very
question decided in November but that's
a matter for the council to consider but
enforcement notice isn't gonna make any
difference to what we're
dealing with in November finally and
importantly barring them on what the
last person said plots five and six
obscure the view to plot three if you I
think you went on sorry back on in the
ladies garden you can barely see plot
three all these suggestions about some
dreadful impact frankly with the utmost
respect have no proper basis in planning
law or judgment and your office has told
you that plot three four and one and two
all sit behind effectively plots five
and six and they will be built one way
or another as your officer correctly
points out it isn't a question of
nothing there there is an X damn
permission those buildings can be
altered if necessary to comply if that's
the position the inspector decides with
the consent so they'll end up being two
buildings there in any event so this
site will be built out with six houses
and we can lawfully do that Thank You
chairman I don't think I need to take up
any more time but again if you have any
questions please ask me and I'll see if
I can help you
Thank You councillor Hinton Thank You
mr. chairman you state that you bought
the site with planning permission and
have built it out according to that
Planning Commission why you know then
applying for a disk as it says in the
description of the proposals in front of
us here
a change of citing site levels Ridge
eaves height and fenestration that
implies the other bill to go to
education as far as we're concerned he
was built out in the right place what
happened last year is your planning
officer invited the architect to make an
application for what's called non
material amendments in other words some
changes to the drawings based on what
was being built on site those are
normally inconsequential matters as part
of that process the office had got the
architect to put a whole set of plans in
as a result of which when I attended the
meeting last year instead of it being a
meeting about non constant non material
amendments in other words minor
immaterial stuff not through my clients
fault but through the council's
machination it had become an entire
fresh planning application that was
turned down by the council we know
effectively on blocks five and six only
it's only because of that position
my clients have to sell these and any
solicitor wants to know they've got
permission we are confident that we have
permission that's why there are
certificates of lawful use applications
we're confident we would get permission
in any event that's why we have Section
73 applications but nonetheless as part
of trying to resolve matters and what
lawyers say without prejudice to our
position we put in planning applications
to regularize what's their saying well
if you approve it it will save all this
time and trouble and expense of going to
an appeal the council for its own best
reasons is persisting in certainly at
the moment it looks like fighting plots
five and six so our position is we're
quite confident we have a very solid
position so much so we told the council
we're going to go for costs but we have
to do that because the council haven't
ignored the question thank you I think
you've got the answer you wanted the
councillor Hinton yes mr. chairman but
they're just to pick up again on one
point you said you built them to
specification or to the permission yes
you had permission for them yes then why
are there so many changes needed you're
blaming Baber for making the changes
well it's not Bayboro making the changes
you you built them in a slightly
different way to the original plank no
the answer to your question is the
change is what we could if there are any
they're what's called non-material I'll
give you an example the ridge Hut right
so as far as we're concerned everything
is non-material our problem is I'm not
the decision-maker and either my clients
the council decided to take the
non-material amendments turning it into
one big planning application and that's
what they rejected as far as we're
concerned we have built in accordance
with the plans the issue among many
issues for the inspector will simply be
these are the approved drawings this is
what's been built
are they materially different we say
they're not the council at the moment is
saying more they think they are and
therefore the inspector says if they are
different am I going to grant permission
in any event we say you should do the
council at the moment of presently
saying no we don't think you should
that's why there is a bun fight as it
were over plus five and six but not over
plots one two four
but I could speak all day and say I
disagree with you you have a right to
disagree with me in the inspector will
decide who's right
I think you've had literally covered it
very well thank you Thank You Jay
any other questions no thank you very
much thank you Jim if you wish to
comment on what we just heard
again the county counselor isn't present
but you've you've got copies of his
speech if there's anything you wish to
comment on you can do at any point right
councillor Parker wrote in for debate
and yeah same question is the last time
again what's the difference between the
height of thank you for completing again
yes the difference for plot three is
just over a meter the difference between
what it was granted planning permission
for in 2015 and what's currently built
it's a meter higher
suppose that mr. K I mean in the plan
the difference between the bridge
heights in Whitehorse house and plot 3
might have been I don't know 10 meters
and the the ground levels whether you're
up or down or immaterial it's the height
of the ridge heart so what is it a
meters different to what it showed to
Whitehorse house the difference iseman
can you her new answer play Thank You
chair the difference between what was
permitted the permitted difference in
height between Whitehorse house and car
3 was just over 2 meters right so block
3 was allowed to be 2 meters higher than
Whitehorse house it's now 3 meters
higher than my courthouse is a meter
probably just one thing to add and
somewhat relevant to the exchange we've
just had and that is in respect to the
appeal inquiry upcoming the figures that
mr. Bailey is quoting are the figures
that the council are relying on for the
purpose of the appeal if it is the case
that the members of the public feel that
those figures are wrong they of course
can make representations to the
inspector in that regard so they will
still have the opportunity to try and to
persuade the inspector that the the
differences are far greater than what
the Council considers thank you I hope
that helps you can still pose be any
other questions councillor Hinton Thank
You mr. chairman
question for the the planning legal
advice that we have sit here based on my
exchange with with the applicant I
understand what a material trying to get
nearer to the mic but I understand what
a material difference ease and it is the
fact that it's different from what was
actually approved so he DS built to a
different specification if you like then
then what was like whether that's a big
difference or a minor difference
it's something we have to decide upon
but it is not as I understand it up to
us as a council to put in a planning
application for an applicant on the
basis that he has a material difference
that he's greater than it should be
Kevin I think I'd need to defer to a
colleague about the process that led us
to 13 months ago when we had the section
73 application what a non-material
amendment is a minor change to a
planning permission that has a much more
straightforward process and less
consultation attached to it but as its
name suggests it sees a minor a change
to a plan commission and obviously in
this instance the council was not
willing to accept that collectively or
individually what was going on fell in
that category and it if I was correctly
my colleagues insisted there should be a
section 73 application but I guess I
wasn't privy to those particular
conversations but I mean effectively a
40 centimeter change I think the
officers opinion was that that is not in
material that is a material change and
therefore section 73 would be the
appropriate recourse for that so a minor
material amendments the question isn't
the point upon which it turns is the
materiality to come back though on that
the the fact that we decided that it
wasn't a minor difference means that
it's then up to the applicant to put in
the section 73 well yes the applicant
submitted a section well yes the
applicant submitted a section 73
application to effectively regularize
the entirety of the development members
considered it as such but the reasons
for the refusal only related to the harm
of plus 5 & 6 that was where that
unacceptable balance was was struck any
other comments members
right just just a point really on on the
these cute the cumulative effect is
probably the one aspect to the material
amendments because it's not just one
area there's been quite a number of
differences would that be right although
some of them might been less than others
is the perhaps the cumulative effect
that has caused the situation the
applications have come about because the
houses have been built and they're not
compliant with the plans that were
approved with the 2014 application I
think the confusion has come with last
year's application which I think the
applicants believed that they have built
everything in accordance with approved
plans but we refuse them and that that
is now the appeal however these changes
are to do with the 2014 application so
it's quite confusing cuz there's quite a
lot of applications going on all at the
same time but these relate to changes to
the 2014 application thank you
any other comments members any other
views anything but again your leave me
in the position where there's no right
okay I'll be the bad boy and with a
heavy heart yes again but I can't see
anything in the planning law that will
allow us to refuse this so from that
point of view I propose that we accept
the rockness recommendations thank you
do we have a second up
Chancellor Osborne do you wish to
comment Thank You mr. chairman yes sir I
agree with the council aplomb we have
very little option here that the
planning planning is planning and I'm
afraid that's the way we all have to
proceed thank you thank you
right members if there's no other
comments I intend to put it to the vote
it's been proposed by the vice chairman
councillor plum seconded by Councillor
Osborn that we accept the officers
recommendation that's in front of you
for approval all those in favor please
show those against that is carried thank
you very much
we move on to item C which is on 69 this
is the last application kakou Hill today
can be found on page 69 of the agenda
and relates to plot floor for DC 1901
for two ain't for is a detached
two-story dwelling in the northeastern
corner of the site there are a
collection of outbuildings
in a yard that shares a boundary with or
pool provides a three-bedroom property
with attached garage the detailing is
similar to that of plot 3 with the
addition of a single story element to
the side
on the left is the front of the dwelling
and on the right is the view of the yard
and outbuildings to the east of the site
from a first-floor window these
photographs are taken from first-floor
windows on the left is looking west with
the with plot three in gray and the
garage the middle shows plot six and
three and the garage and on the right is
another view of the yard and
outbuildings to the east on the left is
a further view of the yard and
outbuildings from the first floor and on
the right is a similar view taken
through one of the panes of the window
the application does not raise any issue
of presidential immunity or impact on a
character or setting of heritage assets
and is recommended for approval with
conditions as set out on page 79 of the
agenda thank you thank you
we have Jill Jackson the games in the
Parish Council just hold on them you
know the likes of frozen who dimmed them
so you could see the pictures clear out
done it as the plot in the top corner of
the development plot for has received
less attention than the other plots
however there are issues relating to all
plots which certainly apply to plot for
your planning officer has asked you to
consider the acceptability in planning
terms of the development pros proposed
in this case plot for planning officer
maintains that this plot does not
benefit completion this is on the report
micron Curtis does not benefit from
permission under B 1401 103 further we
are reminded of the need for consistency
and it seems that we have some
counselors here who need reminding of
that needs to be consistent because last
year as we know July 2018 the
development was refused by Weber and the
certificate of lawfulness that for plot
4 was not successful and it was deemed
unlawful and nothing has happened to
materially change the position the
additional information on the east
boundary sought by Beiber's own survey
was not possible to ascertain and ground
supplements at the boundary is a cause
for concern and plot for is as the other
properties are overbearing an
inappropriate in its setting and the
finished floor levels have increased it
which adds to the problem interestingly
with regard to the heritage we were when
we received the comment from dr. duck I
believe his name is we saw the chain of
emails including the one where he was
asked by the planning office of a
comment he said oh no comment
oh yes but what about this and whatever
and it was as though he was being oh yes
okay if you need me to say this I'll say
that that that is in that email chain
which you will all have been able to see
we're not do not know whether we're
being asked to decide on plot for with
the removal of plot five or with plot
five still standing which makes any
change from the refuser of 2018
difficult to justify if plot five is
present then there is a privacy issue
between plots four and five where the
second-floor windows from plot five have
visibility to the first-floor window in
plot for the distance between plot four
and five is eight meters the access to
the plot for driveway is insufficient
the access to the whole site is far from
clear as the access driveway has been
misrepresented in the applicants plans
the planning officer has actually
misunderstood the Land Registry the Land
Registry we have a copy of the Land
Registry document for steam art and it
shows just the half as was explained
later they do not have the ownership
over the whole drive you have been
misled in July 18 2018 the unacceptable
harm identified above is contrary to the
path the paragraphs I cited for the last
case and it is wrong to say that those
only refer to plots five and six it's
like was suggested before if something
is of greatest harm then that's the one
that attracts the comments there is
still hard with the other plot under the
same terms thank you very much
[Applause]
members I will ask you have you any
questions for the last speaker No thank
you very much any comments you wish to
make thank you
I will move them to an objector which is
Kim butcher
good morning counselors I speak as a
member of keep viewers beautiful a group
of residents who realize the potential
of our village as a leisure destination
and see that the future prosperity of
our village may well depend on its
unspoiled character having been born and
bred in Suffolk I have enjoyed a
lifetime of discovering environmental
gems and buildings throughout the county
I've also been aware of the efforts of
others to preserve these places and
grateful that others have made the
efforts that they have in 1967
legislation was passed allowing the
creation of conservation areas and in
1973 all of the historic core of Rios
and Mary was identified as being worthy
of just that designation a conservation
area it's not just a title the 1990
turned and Country Planning Act made a
general duty of decision-makers that's
you to have special regard to protecting
and enhancing conservation areas unless
there is an overriding public good to be
achieved by doing otherwise it is clear
by looking at Whitehorse house and its
environs that previous decision-makers
have had this Duty very much in mind
when granting planning permissions in
the 46 years of the conservation area
being in existence three new dwellings
that might impact on the area around
Whitehorse has have been constructed
just a food or was up the road we have a
1.5 storey dwelling built in the 1980s
in the 1990s mullions was built in st.
Edmund's Lane and was cut deeply into
the hillside to reduce its overall
height by several metres and in 2006
byron house was built again in San Evans
line and with an overall height exactly
the same as Whitehorse House these
buildings did not arrive in their form
by chance it was a requirement of
planning law I'm sure that the building
heights and locations were taken into
account by the council in 2014 when
granting permission for this site and
indeed the submitted plans indicate
the heights of the planned wings were to
be sympathetic however when it came to
construction it was realized that the
plans as submitters could not be built
at the Builder didn't choose to contact
the council for advice or submit an
inmate an amended plan for approval but
ploughed on while officers can recommend
that you grant this permission it is not
them who are banned by Lord it is you
the decision makers to proceed to grant
a permission in this case you must be
convinced of some public good in so
doing I suggest that the benefits have
maintained in the conservation area and
the 46 years of established and
consistent practice if your predecessor
make such a judgment impossible I urge
you to refuse this application and thus
allows the whole matter to because it
considered in full detail and decided at
the inquiry edge ruled for November
members do you have any questions we
move on then to the applicants agent
again chairman members one last time
on this occasion anyway I'm not going to
again repeat what's gone on you know
that well what I will do is pick up on
two rather important points and your
legal adviser will no doubt confirm this
the last gentleman spoke about
conservation areas and so on you know
the heritage office has looked at this
site and there is no harm that's found
he overstated in fact what the position
is there isn't a duty to improve
conservation areas there is a duty to
preserve or not harm them and therefore
the test I'm sure the officer see your
solicitor nodding with me so that's an
overstatement before
to earth your professional officers and
their outside advisors have looked at
that and in fact because this scheme was
granted permission already we know that
this satisfies the relevant test the
final thing isn't it's a bit of a thank
you the gentleman in front of me again
got something wrong he effectively said
your officers aren't bound by the law
but you are of course you're bound by
the law but so are your officers and
actually it's rather rude to say the
officers are not bound by the law
they're professionals and in fact one
thing any professional planner is bound
to do is to give you advice that they
think is the right advice they are not
and should not be motivated by emotion
or political exigencies so again it's
almost an insult I certainly wouldn't
suggest it as the last gentleman did
that whatever the officers have said you
can go against the advice they have
given you their best advice as you've
heard we have spent a lot of time
professionals on both sides and lawyers
looking at the best way forward and I
just want to finally say thank you to
the officers we haven't quite got there
but hopefully depending what your final
decision is on plot four we have made
the task at the inquiry at least a lot
more focus and I'm very grateful for
that but rest assured what your officers
are saying if we don't agree on
everything they have given you their
professional view and if they didn't do
they would be in breach of their own
professional duty but thank you again
for this thing if there are any more
questions chairman I'm happy to answer
them
Thank You members again I remind you
we're dealing purely with the planning
aspects so bear that in mind any
questions you wish to put no thank you
want to say thank you very much thank
you
thank you I wrote that this particular
point just point out that you know our
officers are under a lot of pressure to
get things right and a dear will plan on
applications as quickly as possible and
to make sure that they're professional
and they are overseen by their superior
officers and the legal people so there's
a lot of work that does go on behind the
scenes and a lot of ice that is given to
us
and I have to say quite often we want to
disagree with them and I think members
and as we do disagree on things with
them but at the end of the day we do
respect their positions and understand
where they're coming from but we have to
balance everything up and that is what
we're attempting to do so just to move
on then we will the county councillor
again isn't present you've got it his
statement if there's any comments that
you wish to question or anything you can
do that during the debate open the
debate who would like to start let's put
it that way
cancel the possibly there that's good
Thank You Jay just over a meter so
they're getting they're getting bigger
look the problem we've got here was the
2014 approval I mean I think they were
crazy to approve two-story dwellings on
that side unfortunately they did and
there's not a lot we can do about that
unfortunately the test the developer we
keep hearing all these things put things
that you're saying but we haven't yet to
say anything on the ground the test will
be with what you come forward with plot
five and six they're the key ones as you
keep telling us now are you going to be
reasonable with the residents in yours
and come up with something which they
find acceptable I have to say the rooms
on all of the houses were probably this
just steepest and therefore the tallest
but I can find in yours I asked on the
site visit why they were so steep and
somebody said well that's because that's
what they're like you walk over the road
to these the new estate over the road
and they're probably half the height
there's no sympathetic development with
plots five and six and they're the ones
that I would want to see you do
something with
for the next time around not much with
nomads this one thankthank you can still
possibly I did let you go on there but
I'm not expecting the applicants to
respond to you at all but really you
know as well as I did we must stick to
the plan side of it that's in front of
us I'm sure that your fears will be
noted by them and perhaps if they feel
that way they may take some on board
that really we're back to this plan and
application any other comments
councillor Barrett well we probably
discussed all the challenges and merits
already that apply broadly to the site
so they similarly will apply to this
hunt house I think I think for me balint
the balance is that we we need to see
between maintaining character and scale
in within this conservation area
so yes it's a brownfield site and it
does replace unsightly buildings but the
scale of these properties does not match
some of the neighbors Biron house and
White Horse house and so you know I feel
that I can't support this this thank you
any other comments
no canceler plumb looks like he's fallen
to me again oh dear yet again with a
heavy heart and I propose that we accept
the officers recommendation do I have a
second up councillor Osborn do you wish
to comment thank you Miss cheering yes
again now I have the same situation as
councillor plum but however we're here
let's get thing resolved thank you thank
you
any other comments members councillor
Parker yeah Thank You chair so I want to
just clarify obviously as a 70 Section
73 a permission this will incur a SIL
liability given that the developers have
hitherto been summarily unreasonable in
its engagement with the community up to
date didn't you know can we can we get
an assurance that I mean how does that
process work with regards to the sexual
ability is this gotta wait until the
appeal comes forward or when does this
actually become liable this still I'll
get the answers for you I'm not sure
that whether they've been particularly
unreasonable but I'm sure the officers
sort of would tell us i I think the
calculation is made at point of
permission and then a demand notice will
be served imagine the status of the
particular plots and it is a matter of
disagreement between the applicant and
officers of the council indeed the
council if you're if you were if you do
support the proposal effectively it's
distilled down to what he and mr. Harman
covered that one is looking forwards one
is looking backwards as a matter of
reasonable judgment we think that plots
one two three and four the development
has been carried out and therefore
section 73 a is the appropriate
mechanism under which to determine these
applications which would render them
liable for silver we've got there at the
end councillor Parker
any other comments no well against
Hinton just very quickly it's my
understanding that still has to be paid
before you actually commence development
so presumably that would have to be paid
virtually immediately well I think it
would be as I said demand notice that is
that he served I am led to believe that
there can be arrangements and Hart
payments if they've contact before
commencement doesn't it the give the
sill rules are extremely complex but
broadly speaking you're right yes and
the other comments
no I've been proposed by the first
chairman canceled plans seconded by
Councillor Osborn then we accept the
officers recommendation that's in front
of us on your papers all those in favor
please show so treat your hands up
please
we picked up one yes okay those against
that is carried they thank you very much
I got at seven for anyway let's let's do
it again
what yes please show in favor again
counselor oh and as changed our minds
which is fair at that party
so you've listened to the if that's
right and so that's that makes it seven
those against okay I hope I didn't think
I've counted wrong but we've gotta
correct then that is carried thank you
very much members that is the bureau's
applications don't we we have Hadley
members do you wish to have a five
minute counter break yeah we have a
please be back by five and twenty past
twelve
you
members were packing committee its 1228
right we're now on item number six day
on page 83 and we have Vincent to take
us see those those do things Thank You
Jake good afternoon members very quick
here we have a hybrid application we
have an outline element for North Point
65 hectares of employment juice and we
have a full element for 170 dwellings
so obviously the outline you're looking
at the principle for the residential
you're looking at the fine detail the
report fully sets out what I think are
the key planning issues so we won't
rehearse those here and now in terms of
oh yeah sorry
in terms of context a large red line
opposite what's known as Weaver's meadow
estate which is currently near
completion or completed that was a
persimmon development we have the a 1071
hips which road along the top the red
line red dot goes the B 1070 and that's
not working and then oldest Avenue which
is the one that runs north-south below
the blue dot that is what will provide
access to both elements the employment
and the residential there's something
very peculiar happening
to the slide see pressing happen so we
are in context we're on the north east
edge of Headley the closest shot where
you can see the modern development not
quite complete in that shot opposite the
application site in terms of constraints
very few constraints affect the site
there is a footpath public footpath that
runs through the middle of the site
shown in the green dashed line there is
one to the south but outside the site
and there is a scheduled monument up at
the top with the little black dot that
is is flashing so relatively
unconstrained another shot taken from
the air looking northwards of the site
which sits in there if we swing around
and take it from a different angle what
you'll notice is that the site already
has three access points built at the
time of construction of Weaver's meadow
and Ellen Aldous Avenue they will be
used for the next phase of development
if you're minded to grant planning
permission in terms of the local plan
this site is contrary to the local plan
allocation in as much as it is allocated
for employment uses so obviously the
residential element is a departure from
the local plan the biscuit coloured area
HS 15 was identified for residential
that is now Weaver's meadow in terms of
your emerging local plan the site known
as la o tu 9 is the application site at
the moment that is still allocated for
employment use and not residential use
but you'll notice la o - 8 below it is
identified for up to 500 dwellings
employment uses community uses including
sites for a school sites for a community
centre
but the only way that you can bring la
28 forward is by having la 29 developed
in terms of the sequence of events we
have had some representations that I
didn't have the chance to put into your
report and I do need to run through them
very quickly Headley Town Council has
reaffirmed its objection to the proposal
they cite country to land use allocation
in terms of the residential element they
don't believe that the footpath network
included in the scheme is sufficient to
provide safe movement they're concerned
that retail use within the employment
area would undermine Headley's shops
will i'll deal with all these in turn as
we go through the presentation they
believe that there is a lack of
community facilities in Hadley already
and this residential component would put
extra pressure on those facilities and
therefore they continue to object
Suffolk County Council water in floods
they have some technical issues that
they need to resolve my feeling is that
if members have mind you to ground
planning permission we can deal with
those by way of condition as section 106
agreement is being negotiated the NHS
have written to say that they will not
be looking for contributions towards
extended GP services Suffolk County
Council infrastructure have indicated
that the majority of the bids that they
would normally ask for can be dealt with
by Syl were this to get planning
permission but they have asked for
two hundred and ninety four thousand one
hundred and sixty five pounds it's a
contribution to early years build costs
and that is requested through section
106 Suffolk County highways have no
objection
they've just recommended some conditions
in terms of neighbor letters we've had
an additional eight objections from
people living within Weaver's meadow
estate and one that we described as
being neutral I've set out on the screen
all the reasons that have been cited
most of those already in the report from
other objectors that we received earlier
what I've done is highlighted in red the
ones that aren't in my view in planning
view material I was reference to general
dislike of the proposed although it
isn't specific enough there's reference
to loss of property value members will
realize that that isn't a material
planning consideration there is concern
that there isn't sufficient information
accompanying the outline planning
application I think that just is a
confusion as to what you would expect
with an outline as we're only dealing
with the principle we don't have a lot
of information that is quite normal and
there is concern expressed that there
are no bungalows within the scheme that
is not correct because there are
bungalows within the scheme and I will
point out the location of those so in
terms of the outline element that's at
the northern tip at the junction of
Eleanor dose Avenue and the a 1071 this
is shown as two buildings one of five
and a half thousand square feet one of
four and a half thousand square feet but
that is only indicative in the initial
submission back in 2017 this has been on
our books for a number of years this was
going to be residential and as offices
we felt that didn't create a balanced
proposal so we have negotiated
employment use of this northern tip the
advantage here is that it now has its
own vehicle access as shown with the
turquoise triangle originally the access
was further down and be shared with the
residential element and we didn't think
that was particularly safe nor did
Suffolk County highways so that's that
is a big advantage in our view
this is achieving potential for jobs
also the council not that it's a
material planning consideration I think
members would be concerned that there is
a significant loss of employment land
involved in this application how on
earth do we ensure that jobs are
provided the answer is this site would
be transferred to the council for a
parent and we would be able to deliver
development and jobs that we thought
appropriate through our own resources in
that way persimmon who aren't a
commercial developer they're a housing
developer don't have to worry about
trying to do commercial development but
the council would do it
instead and of course we still have
phase two
if that gets through the local planning
stages with a significant amount of
Employment Development within it so what
we're looking at here is a balance
because we do know that we need
additional housing at the moment we do
know that we can't demonstrate a
five-year housing lens supply this we
think is the right balance to strike
through creating jobs for ourselves for
the people of the district a very good
mix of units are now included something
we didn't have before so there's a broad
range of one bed to bed three-bedroom
for bid units we don't have the big
months to 5 bits and we don't have a
majority that are the 1 bits the earlier
scheme was 171 starter homes it was I've
described it in the report as Monogue
tenure there was very little variety
very little balance so this is
effectively a completely new scheme
that's emerged over the two years that
we've been negotiating we do have the
35% affordable housing we do have a good
split between rented and shared
ownership we have achieved pepper
potting throughout the whole of this
estate so we don't have one enclave of
affordable housing it is mixed it is
tenure blind they will look like the
rest of the houses on the development
in terms of story Heights you might not
be able to pick it up there between can
we use the pointer we've lost a mouse
thank you those are now included here in
this area which is good because that's
adjacent to I've got the next 16 garden
so we've been thinking about trying to
minimize the impact for neighbors but
the majority of properties are either
two-story there's a smattering of two
and a half stories and there's one
element that's three story at the bottom
here which is a gateway featuring to the
estate from the south again parking
meets your standards it's hard to
discern what I'm trying to show on there
that's merely to show that every plot
we've worked out all the parking spaces
for every plot on there and we're
satisfied that it complies with your
your standards which is good in 2017 we
dislike the design immensely so much so
that we said if it stayed in that form
we would recommend refusal not persimmon
Diddy's respond positively to that
reaction from us and we began
renegotiating but why it was so poor is
we had the shared access points on there
but what we had was all the parking
virtually all of the parking was out of
the front of the properties in sort of
hearts tangles right the way through the
estate and whenever you looked at those
properties from a public vantage point
you had to look at the Twinings through
large areas of parking off the street
which we thought wasn't the sort of
character that you would expect anywhere
else in the district
so is it was very car dominated and
again all that rate represents parking
within the street scene
nothing was beside or behind of it
garages so what we now have four-wheel
we have an access point at the South the
existing access on an access point at
the the north but what we've done is
we've worked with pursuing to create
character areas so the piece in the
middle we've tried to design with them
as a village green
so you'll notice all that yellow is
continuous frontage of dwellings there
is a large area of village green the
public footpath that exists will stay
and run through the middle of the site
but there are no vehicles within the
Front's of those properties obviously
the access road goes through the green
but that will be a shared another shared
a raised table and that will be surfaced
in material that doesn't match the road
and will have almost like village entry
signs north of that and the south of
that that's an incredible difference
from the scheme that came in before that
had roads in front of all those
properties another that shows that on
every corner we now have houses that
have jeweler elevations so the flanks of
those properties are as well designed as
the France so wherever you look at that
there will be some point of interest in
the design rather than looking at blank
walls on all the corners we have feature
buildings at the center of the green so
that you're entering and leaving the
village green in design terms and all
those properties enjoy access to the
village green without cars entering that
space so it'll be pedestrian friendly in
terms of appearance what you get is on
the right that is a foot way cycle way
that's entirely pedestrian friendly it
has the look of a village green it looks
less like in a state a more like
something you would expect to see
in in Hadley and more rural parts of the
district so we're very pleased with the
cooperation that we had for from
persimmon to achieve that and obviously
that space looks like dead space but
over time of course it will become
animated people will sit out there
they'll hopefully play they'll the dogs
they'll enjoy that space and any member
of the public has access to that it
needs public open space so anyone in the
area can enjoy that another shot this is
the western half of the green and that
was a depression on the left there is
effectively a pond in very wet weather
but normally it would be dry and again
you have the foot waste cycle we linking
that right the way through if houses
fronting the village green you can see
on there as well in terms of the
property on the top left that's a flank
elevation that's fully detailed and on
the bottom right another fully detailed
elevation so we're very pleased with the
look of of that and again we can start
to think about how that could be
animated by human activity another
character area we've created this it's
interesting space that is you enter and
leave through what are almost Sentinel
buildings they've been carefully
positioned so you feel that you're
entering a new space a new character we
have these permit roof garages it's free
a uniform appearance but the houses are
set back to create this little square of
shared surface within which you've
planted some trees in terms of elevation
you get that a very formal space
something you won't find on many other
estates and years what we try to do is
Basim these create interest throughout
the whole development and there are
little pockets of this where we've tried
something something different so it
doesn't look like the ubiquitous stately
you might find in other districts key
features we got the three-story gateway
building at the the south of site shown
at the top we've even gone to the point
of ensuring that at the end of each
street there is a building that
dominates that Vista rather than looking
into a garage or
down the side of a property so you'll
see that at that point the central gave
of that building sits right at the end
of that to create a visual . in terms of
detailing I have to say persimmon we've
worked hard on persimmon they have
pulled out all the stops what we have
here is a high level of detailing so we
have a dental string course running
halfway along we have the dental gable
feature below the eaves we have this
little feature in the the Oriole in the
apex of the gable stone sills flat brick
arches we are we've negotiated excellent
palliative materials you'll be familiar
with the idea that we're trying to push
more towards clay we do have some clay
in less or less concrete we have brick
walls I think that that elevation shows
just how far we've come in terms of
raising the bar and I know that's
something that members wanted us to do
and gradually we are cranking up the
design quality and to be fair on this
site persimmon has been incredibly
cooperative another shot nicely detailed
building and rather than the blank flank
that you would normally get what persona
was done with this is to create a fully
detailed gable but we weren't quite
happy with the position of that top
left-hand window so we've agreed with
persimmon to move it to create a bit of
balance and that goes right the way
through so there's something that fine
detailing in the brickwork we do have a
three story building at the southern end
and that image doesn't do it justice
because that looks like a flat quite a
monolithic building but because it has
flared wings what it'll actually look
like we did a quick model in the office
is that so it has quite a bit of
articulation the gable is pronounced so
you get shadow line the windows beside
it are pushed back in behind the
brickwork you'll get a lot of shadow
going on and that actually breaks down
the bulk of and the mass of that
building quite nicely there is precedent
in the area within this part of Hadley
there's another shot
we do have three-story buildings just to
the west of this site so it isn't it
isn't unusual what we've done is keep it
to the absolute minimum to create that
gateway feature that's the only three
story element within this we're just
quickly should just show you some more
house types we do have the bungalows I
know members like to see they weren't
included in the original proposal we
have five and they will be affordable as
well so that's that's good that's
something we've been looking for to get
some affordable bungalows again the
fully elevated detail and that just goes
right the way through you will have seen
before that we don't like the bigger
doors because it creates doesn't create
the right balance so what we're looking
at is something a bit smaller actually
creates perfect balance and then the
roof and the dormers don't dominate so
we've gone through every house type and
work with persimmon to do something a
little bit special again women are
starting to take a lead in providing
sustainable elements the proposal we
have here all the plots with proposed PV
panels we have all the garages with
electric charging points we do have
women committing to lay ducting to the
communal parking courts so that
retrofitting of electricity can be put
in for people who then buy them with and
have an electric vehicle but don't have
a garage this is actually I think from
my answer first what a purse women are
now proposing is to put some public
charging points within the development
so adjacent to public open space we've
got one in the north and one in the
south should we just show that so we
have one here within the open space
there's one on the south where anyone
will be able to plug in and charge up
their their electric vehicle so that's
really put in a sense of persimmon ahead
of the competition and I'm hoping that's
what you're beginning to see all those
months ago when you started pushing us
to get things like this included
developers are now beginning to
trying outdo each other with taking that
further so that represents a first for
us within the district so we're pleased
at that we have these two features that
certain times during the particularly
heavy rainfall they will have some water
in them they are actually new habitats
as well so we're creating biodiversity
within the proposal we have large areas
of greenery we have massive amount of
open space and landscaping again habitat
creation women have committed to
providing ecological mitigation within
the development so things like that a
little hedgehog gap fencing and bits and
pieces we can get some nesting boxes on
properties all of that is being proposed
we even have a circular gym trail and
what we're going to ask persimmon to do
is provide gym equipment the people can
use when they're out Rett creating you
can go out and pump iron or do some
press ups or bench presses as you go
around there I've just shown the gym
trail but there are a myriad number of
footpaths that run right through this
development and Link it to the outside
world so it links it back to the Headlee
and the residential develop to the west
but also the countryside to the yeast I
have suggested some recommendations to
changes to the recommendation simply
because we had those we had additional
comments received they have been
circulated so yes the extra so that they
come forward we didn't know that where
they're becoming was the request for
money from Suffolk County Council for
the education we are looking for a
contribution to Ward's the Suffolk coast
recreational avoidance and mitigation
strategy so this is the contribution
because the site is within 13 kilometers
of the river store and we are required
to seek money contributions to mitigate
impact for additional visits
the sister II we also have asked for the
run user a condition we suggested to 106
to secure the gym trail and equipment so
in a nutshell that's a very quick run
through the there we are recommending
approval as set out on the modified
recommendation thank you Jeff
thank you right members we have no
parish council rep we have no objector
we have no supporter but we do have the
applicants agent Stuart
if you'd like to come forward and
address the committee you know the
procedures I work with you
good afternoon chair members of the
planet Committee for those of you who
don't know me I'm Stuart macadam I'm a
Senior Planner with persimmon Holmes and
Suffolk there's a recognized national
and local imperative to deliver
sufficient housing members will be aware
of the increasing difficulty that some
of the constituents face get in the
housing lada and high demand for
affordable homes particularly in Suffolk
the council's core strategy and emerging
local plan highlight key urban areas
such as hardly as the focus for growth
the application site has remained
undeveloped since its allocation in the
2006 plan the MPP F states that there's
no reasonable prospect of an application
for land can move forward for the use of
our keys in the plan that applications
for alternative use of Milan should be
supported where the proposed use for
contribute to meeting an unmet need for
employment development in the area such
as the delivery of much-needed housing
this proposal seeks to deliver 170 1 to
2 1 to four-bedroom dwellings the
majority of which are family homes
however it also retains part of the site
for employment use which would provide
10,000 square feet of commercial floor
space suitable flexible to life or a
number of end users which could deliver
in excess of 40 jobs the proposal
includes policy compliant affordable
units 60 in total which accord with the
requirements of your housing officer
these units would be secured through a
legal agreement which can assure that
priority is given to local people who
are currently in housing work in West
the submission falls positive
discussions with your officers over a
lengthy period of time as you've heard
from the case officer and significant
amendments have been secured which we
believe will deliver high quality design
and layout a key objective is to provide
a green development that's
environmentally sustainable and which
includes nfo energy-efficient homes
incorporating PV arrays capable of
delivering a saving of 10% and co2
emissions electric charging points for
vehicles ultra-fast broadband to all
homes and a gem tree on circular Fupa
what can own decide point I'd like to
make is the key objective of the
government which is to supply a
significant boost in a number of new
homes Daubert for some in homes as
committed to doddering new houses and as
owner of the site can deliver these
units well within the five years as
detailed in the delivery statements
submitted and agreed with the council
well the proposal contains elements are
contrary to the adopted local plan would
believe their overriding material
considerations outweigh any harm
boosting the council's housing supply
delivering high quality housing and a
highly sustainable location compatible
with surrounding land uses and retaining
employment lines which should be
transferred to the king sulforaphane
I welcome the positive officer
recommendation and hope that members can
approve the application
thank you for affording me the
opportunity to address you today thank
you
also if there's any questions for you I
have one which I just want to I put it
to Vincent at the briefing and that I am
assured that the footways and footpaths
on the site all sort of be tarmacked
rather than these grass verges that you
know i'm referring to that you had on
your very corner persimmon site which
were absolute disaster ID if there's any
on this I'm told so I'm quite pleased
there now the other question is that
render people are beginning to say that
there's too much render on some of the
houses that have been produced nowadays
and I note from what you were showing us
there's a lot of all brickwork which is
which is good so certainly persimmon
seems to be listening and so I hope that
you know you'll take that back to them
that are certainly I'm very pleased to
see the improvements they're making but
you can confirm that there are no grass
surges which will be coming I saw in
terms of verges we're happy to agree
details by means of a condition we will
be
detailed landscape drawings which will
be required under that condition but
happy to give consideration obviously to
concerns that you've gotten happy to to
come to an agreement through officers to
deliver that fact thank you but I dare
say come and repair all the ones we left
in great corn are that four sevens cost
but over at the variable um pick and
that bill up through County Council
anyway our servers any questions
councillor Ayers thank you very
impressive it's fantastic I just have
three questions really one of them is we
have a problem with an estate in Sudbury
where several highways haven't taken on
the roads who will be responsible for
the roads yeah the roads within a
development we'd be proposing for
adoption by the County Council so we
wouldn't be taking more under management
company or anything so that we'd
alternately behind it over and brought
up to various standards as a fact
developments built out any of them gonna
be homes for life we don't have policy
so no that's not something to do as part
of this proposal not proposing it's just
the affordable housing that we have and
which is policy compliant and the third
one is sorry the question if you travel
abroad particularly in France so many
homes actually do have underground
parking I know it's not specified here
but maybe it's something could be
considered in future underground parking
we could consider and other schemes as
it comes forward and subject to
discussion with officers the Plymouth
undergoing parking as it's very costly
to provide that if you go to undercroft
Park and as opposed to underground you
still have that cost implication as well
it also pushes houses higher and
particular flats where you would expect
to see potentially undergoing parking it
makes may be a three storey block of
flats an extra story higher and also
creates dead frontage
on the ground floor but underground park
in which you've particularly raised as a
particular cost of costly to provide so
we're doing generally do that with a
house builder we try to provide a mix of
parking courts own plot cutlet on
frontage parking as well it's just that
I know particularly when I've been in
France that whereas you would have a
cellar half of the Senate would be Liam
Cole I think you've made your point
about angered over Parker yes for
persimmons I think they've gone quite a
long way at the moment it has perhaps a
step too far for them but perhaps in the
future
Cancellara I was born yeah thank you
cheering Thank You Stuart for that I'm
just a little bit just clarification of
the employment land so in other words
you're just going to provide space and
then that will be have to be built out
by others we're housing developers we're
doing develop commercial land
so the reason that's a hybrid
application is to allow someone else to
come in and construct the employments
able to create all the jobs we're happy
to do that but over and above that we
are happy to come to an agreement with
the council through discussions with
with Vincent about actually handing that
over to the council so they are in
charge of their own destiny to create
jobs and take that forward so that's
where we are happy to do that in this
particular instance Hensler question I
was just about to say a pound for land
is not bad but obviously you need to
develop with it and obviously we need
skilled labour to come in so yeah I mean
we do have a commercial interest that we
begin to teeners forward but we very
much see this as an opportunity to what
the council and I'll allow them to
decide what's appropriate for that part
of the site annulment over is clearly
still in accordance with the approved
development plan so that's the the offer
we've made three discussions we believe
it's prolly our when went for both both
accounts or line for persimmon homes
definitely a win-win
Karen thank you - yeah absolutely great
to see the greenery and everything else
would you be having a management company
- to sort that out the that's still up
for to be I mean the situation with many
councils knows they don't want to take
on these areas because of the Bodden and
the course involved in that so we are
happy to do it through a management
company and now it's probably what our
proposal would be just now but we could
we can discuss that with the counts like
she mentioned be approved until the
appropriate way to to come out forward
yeah the only thing I would say with
management companies is that there
doesn't seem to be a lot of control over
them I've heard lots of complaints of
where there's been management come in
and administer these estates and look
after them and within five six years the
costs become colossal so whilst the
people that want all these green areas
and open spaces and all that there is a
cost to that and it can become so so bad
that people can't afford to buy the
houses start with and just recently
there's been I think somewhere inside
the area there's been one highlight it
might be leung mei-fun actually it's
been highlighted where these cost of
we've gone silly I know you've no
control over that but I think it's
something it needs a fresh look
something like that I'm not sure
management committees are the right
answer to solving these problems but
it's just my view you don't have to
comment and counsel Osborn just state
that people's part was very much like
that but they what they've done is that
the the actual management of that part
been done by the trust and two directors
which all of those houses that are there
however it does cost 400 pounds a year
for each of those houses I suppose but
don't let management companies I mean
the are I think our policy is that he's
handed over to the village or town
council to look after to start with
which is a better way of doing it
because why should a new housing estate
have to pay twice for precept you know
just because your house was built ten
years ago when we didn't ever management
companies and they have and Town Council
looks after that site for nothing should
look after all the sites so you just
spread the cost so I'm reminded heads of
Buzzbee we must ask the question there
is fine this is as good a question as
yours was joyful I'm confused he's why
we're bringing this site forward rather
than the one that is designated for
housing the 500 and we can't have access
to it before this one's developed I
don't I couldn't understand that could
you explain all the states coming
forward primarily no because we own the
site and as a say that we can develop
out it's not viable commercially to
provide service ports for example and
we're not commercial developers we are
holding developers as your officer said
to make sense for the site to be
developed to force them lead into the
second site that's another site that we
have auctions on and your applications
will come forward for that say as well
for housing so you have you open you up
the only tall you have options to own it
because of that that to me is that
scientist far more central for Hadley
and looked better placed for residential
than the site that we're talking about
this morning which actually would be
better for as it was designated for
employment the only thing and if you
develop it all out for employment as you
have
to pass the employment uses together
then get into phase two as that comes
forward as well
and as part of the public exhibition
what we did on the original application
which has been changed quite
dramatically is that the people loving
and Weaver's made or don't want to see
employment an opposite there in the
driver see housing in that particular
location thank you there's any other
questions and I'll go to the offices I'm
still not sure why it's better to have
build a site at the top and then you're
gonna have if you're going to develop
the site out beneath it you've then got
to bring all of the traffic through the
built up site to get to the second one
it's the question you need to put to the
spectrum well that's what I've asked and
trying to get well he's given you an art
so you don't agree with it so we'll have
to pick it up with offices I think
canceler Hinton yeah it comes to come to
that point really as well because the
the largest site has got something like
seven hectares of sorry five and a bit
hectares of the employment land where
this site is total of seven just over
seven hectares and was originally
designated to be all employment land
drinks all round on Strasbourg but it
just seems it just seems a bit strange
that when these two when this site as a
whole including Weaver's meadow or
whatever it's called now came forward it
was split as housing that side
commercial that side so when it was
developed it was on the basis that was
going to be commercial on the other side
of the road so to say now you don't like
motion it strange question to the
speaker keeping keeping commercial
property as close to the 1071 or 1070 so
as possible it makes a lot of sense
moving it away further into the new part
of the larger part of the thing is it's
logical would you like to comment on
that well only to say that the nub of
the site at the top of the sacred plants
knob no but that will be a commercial
area which is viewed from the bypass
when to that but you know we've heard
the say no for some considerable years
and no one is coming forward indeed the
only employment application that came
forward to the council was rejected
because of the Empire of the b8 use on
the residential properties so that field
and no one else has shown any interest
for our employment or in that particular
say the time will tell whether the
employment allocation which was
highlighted in the core strategy and the
emerging plan will indeed come forth for
employment what we hear is that there
may be school for some service plots and
these service plots could an effect be
provide and the northern doubled the
development at first the rear the case
will choose to to develop that oh and
although businesses to expand from
hardly for example but we just can't
find any which is interesting the same
forward and it was our case in 2006 or
so some quite considerable time now that
it's laying vacant and you know we see
has no opportunity as I'm sure the
council do to provide much-needed
housing and address five-year land
supply issues we ordinance a we can get
and say and the statement says that we
agreed with the council sure that we can
deliver all 170 units well within five
years probably just shy of four years we
can deliver all these units thank you
the site is deliverable now any other
comments or any other questions sorry no
oh yes
Chancellor parent yes and it might fall
under the question about the management
committee but who who would pay in the
future for the maintenance of the gym
trail equipment because that's obviously
probably more than your average plague
women that we'd all fall under if the
council didn't take it one we don't
really expect the council to take corner
say it would fall to the management
company as part of the details of the
management company would have to submit
that and agree with the council what we
are proposing to do and what form the
management plan we take and what would
happen on an annual basis a number of
a sconce equipment when it would be at a
place in the lake so that would be dealt
with under the management company follow
up with your experience of person and
the developments is this sort of
equipment used because I've seen it in
parts where you never see anyone using
it does it's not like going to the gym
well we believe it has used I've used it
myself not very often but I'm not very
good at it and it tires me out but you
know I the experiences that will be used
and the beauty about the gem equipment
is that can be used by a range of Ages
as well it's not just young people but
it's all the people as well just to keep
them and give them a purpose for do not
circular route so it's beneficial and I
think it would be used
we were happy again by condition to deal
with the specific equipment that would
be provided so if there's one type of
equipment that isn't particularly
attractive then we could substitute that
for for something else so we've shown
illustrations but were happy to discuss
with the case on the parts and
Recreation Service what would be
appropriate here thank you
any other questions yes councillor Busby
since you struggled since 2006 to find
people that have developed that in the
employment land would it be would baby
be able to buy the rest of it at one
pound per naught point six five better I
think you probably know the answer to
thank you
any other questions no right thank you
very much thank you is that officers
that you wish to comment okay I think
there was a slight fear of members that
we don't particularly like management
committees too much but hopefully
they'll take that away I'm think about
it in future but we are where we are
with the application and that's the end
of the public speakers no Canada
councillor councillors Dawson Fraser and
grand and I haven't heard anything from
so I have to see
they're happy / - you can't slow hinton
yeah just a couple of points firstly the
the two areas that might fill up with
water when it rains that this summer but
when we do tend to get it it comes in
big lumps those are presumably part of
the Sun scheme are they gonna be managed
by the County Council or are they gonna
fall under the remit of this management
company and will they be suitable health
and safety equipment provided in case
somebody falls into it when it has got
water in it
the second point would be the three
story elements that were so proudly
promulgated by the officer in their
strange around the corner type sort of a
layout are they flats or are they
dwelling that are three stories high and
lastly there are several other
properties on the site that appear to be
sort of - and are they two and a half or
are they three story does accommodation
in the roof on a two story to story
property make it a three story one or is
it a a half a story Vince is happy to
answer all three questions for you
safety equipment will be provided around
each of those water features one of the
technical points that we're discussing
with Suffolk County Water and floods is
simply the gradient of the terraced
approach so that were somebody to fall
in as well as having the life ring they
would actually have a shelf a series of
shelves so that they wouldn't
plop straight in indeed in terms of
overall maintenance that's something
that Suffolk County Council water flats
will will resolve if there's hardly ever
any water in it it may be that it's part
of the management company however that's
one of the technical points that will
come out in the discussion
the corner turning units are actually
apartments they're not townhouses
occupying three floors and the other
properties that you refer to are
actually two and a half stories they are
- they are two stories with dormers and
rooms in the roof to be a three story
building you'd have to have a vertical
face of three storeys in fact there's no
difference between the profile of a
two-story dwelling and their two and a
half story well as we've demonstrated
the previous committees the only
difference you see are there some some
little dormers in them in the roof so
they're two and a half or you could say
that they're two storey with a dormer
you can't see the three-story you might
do that's very clear to you now John any
other comments
Kancil Jamison the traffic on the 1071
is very busy at best times in the
morning the tails back from the
roundabout so is there anything we can
do about encouraging public transport a
great point in the 106 we have got the
reference to travel packs but as part of
the weavers meadow development there is
section 106 money to improve a number of
junctions along that route but that
doesn't happen until further development
happens so actually where this
development to be approved and proceed
it then opens the pot for additional
money to carry out improvements but what
we have ensured is this is cycle
friendly so at least in that sense we're
enabling people to cycle more easily I'm
not familiar with the bus routes through
here I'd have to rely on local knowledge
thank you any other comments
transfer translating this this 1:06
money when you're talking about
junctions etc does this just apply to
the ten seventy or would it apply to for
instance the be ten seventy and the
access through Benton Street down
towards the a12 which should to be much
more popular I have to say from some of
the people have moved into Hadley in
recent times and the the routing dip
switches slide where we refer to all the
comments received we are
but that explains so what Suffolk County
highways of said is there is a planning
obligation from phase one development in
which highway contributions of quarter
of a million indexed is payable to
Suffolk County Council prior to material
occupation in respect of phase - this is
for highway improvements due to the
extra vehicular trips so that includes
beagle roundabout 1871 b11 1/3 Swan Hill
speed reduction on the a 1071 no
reference there to the B 1070 what is
under negotiation it's not a matter
before you but within the second phase
was it the LA the next big chunk there
is discussion that's how that could be
connected right round through to the
south of of Hadley so effectively they
need to create a nice new link around
the entire east of Hadley but that's not
something that's on offer within this
proposal but you're not just quickly
this is all a bit comes from the site
plan what Stuart was explaining is that
persimmon owned this site and can bring
it forward they don't technically own
the site to the south so they cannot yet
bring it forward but also Ellen alders
Avenue which provides the access stops
short of the next boundaries hunches
they might be a ransom strip it would
all have to be served off Ellen Aldus
Avenue
and because that's still in the emerging
local plan this is the one that can can
move forward and what we have in the
statement to come on ground which is
something we've encouraged developers to
sign up to is by 2021
we'd have 65 of these units constructed
by 2022 an additional 65 and by 2023 the
last 40 units would be built so within a
three-year build program that would all
be built we would have all the
affordable units and then we'd be ready
to look at the next stage if it's
approved which delivers the school the
community centers sports residential and
employment and presumably the the amount
of development within that is sufficient
then to deal with whatever rent some
strips there are and whatever
infrastructure costs there are
associated with skirting hadley it's a
much bigger site so it can generate a
lot more contributions hopefully towards
infrastructure that's why I say this one
needs to come forward first so the next
bit would be my answer thank you very
much Chancellor Harris can we go to the
uncinate about me I'm so money for the
preschool money that would be available
my question is this we don't have a
sixth format hardly so I wonder where
that money would go would it go to
Sudbury or would it go to cell fat16
form expansion well that would be
something for our colleagues at Suffolk
County Council to decide that is beyond
our like if that's something you'd have
to take up with your County colleagues
well yeah that's potentially something
that they are actively exploring I mean
what they've set out there are the the
figures that they would seek to bid for
through the civil process to facilitate
additional places where they are
required in order to meet kind of the
catchment of the future occupiers that
the key figure the one that has a degree
of certainty attached to it or complete
certainty attached to it is that 106
contribution which is yours at that
early year build can occur and that's
that's captured through the legal
agreement as opposed to a kind of a
bidding process that lots of different
infrastructure providers are kind of
them arguing over and we choose who to
give the money to yes students from
happy can go to
Suffolk wand and can go to sub we can't
though and others so there's something
they would have to sort out on trade and
other questions right tensor Jemison
tell if I cancel it must be the Parish
Council said they got concerns about the
effect of the employment effectiveness I
imagine the high street the amount of
floor space involved here is less than
the government's threshold for requiring
sequential test so it falls below the
threshold at which it's deemed that
there is likely to be an impact on other
retail areas it's a relatively modest
amount of retail floor space in the
scheme of things not deemed to have the
good news is that the permission would
allow a mixture of uses potentially it
would allow for the traditional b1 uses
which is light industry office research
and development it would allow for
retail shop it would allow for
professional services and would allow
for restaurant not drive-through but a
restaurant or any combination there in
provided it doesn't exceed 10,000 square
feet so our colleagues in assets and
economic development would then come
forward with proposals which would have
to come forward with a full application
and at that point we'd know more about
what was intended that's both lease
anyway I've got two more speakers I
think councillor Busby and was it
canceled apart then there's awesomes
cancelled must be lost right
my favourite retail around that part and
one thought just you had a slight there
the last one the add up it said NHS no
requirement for a fun surprising 170
houses and they're not looking for a
financial contribution only are they so
flush with money they don't need
that's what's recent as the 27
oh yeah so I mentioned that they must
have enough to deal with expected
demands but that's something we'd have
to take up with them outside of this
meeting but that was a formal comment
any other comments members Chancellor
Hinton on that last point normally the
NHS comment comes from the property
services part not from the medical
services so for instance the GPS would
not be included in that consultation so
they might be saying we're struggling
but all that the NHS would do is build
another room on the surgery for them
nobody you need but just another room
note that we have what we have in front
of us did you wish to comment well not
really I mean
councillor Henson's point is is right I
mean it's really for the NHS to work out
who's leading who but ultimately it's a
civil matter
I mean if circumstances change or the
position evolves and it will be for them
to make a bill through the seal process
if they feel that there is a requirement
but it is really for them to work out if
there is that requirement or not but GP
practices are private companies they are
not public organisations we'll move on
any other comments
in the absence of already proposal come
forward I shall do from the chair the
officers recommendation do I have a
seconder all over the place now cancer
Parker did you wish to second I'll
second that sure yes sorry you did you
wish to speaks what I meant to say no
thank good thank you
right and now other comments all those
in favor of the officers recommendation
in front of you please show does that
unanimous I can't see the Hemnes of all
of them yes Mary and council I was born
I couldn't see how either of you two
right that's fine that's up carry that's
past members I think we've got to the
end you might be in time for lunch the
date of the next meeting is Wednesday
the 11th of September and that is all
those members that can be present for
the site inspection please show that's
next Wednesday isn't it Mick strange
about the second of no Ferb anybody who
can't make it so you can write for
everybody other than Chancellor bye
thank you declare the meeting closed